foreign
go to indochino right now and they are
offering our listeners any premium
premium suit for just 3.99 that's up to
50 off at indochino.com and when you
enter promo code charger checkout plus
they're offering free shipping there's
no reason not to try your first
custom-made suit with a deal that's good
go to indochino.com and use promo code
church at checkout show is also brought
to you by onnit.com go to audit.com and
use promo code Church to save 10 on all
of their amazing optimization products
like strong Bode strong bone New Moon
stream tech Community export
oh [__]
Wednesday the 27th
July
oh kick that [__] mulele bong hits
for Jerry's kicks got suckers
Church of What's Happening Now
old old Ted Nugent
it's a [__] free-for-all [__] suckers
Uncle Joey here my main little brother
Lee Syed first off we got to open up an
apology I get a call Monday from Lisa
yet
about four o'clock that uh he came over
here and the lights wouldn't turn on and
the [__] air was off
some [__] and he turned on the
computer you know Lee confuses me with
his
jargon so let me tell you the other side
of the [__] story
Sunday I have a great weekend with the
family I get off the antibiotics you
know me I'm free and clear I'm doing
some kettlebells I'm walking the
neighborhood
Sunday morning I go to Jujitsu 12
o'clock class great day I breathe I get
beat up no different than any other day
Monday I go let me go back there
and I had a meeting on Tuesday
and we had episode 400 Monday night we
had Esther cool and we had dice tonight
so we had the weekend planned Everything
Is Beautiful ready to go
I go to Jujitsu at 12 and I stay for the
mobility class it's a little hot here
but I'm not blaming on the heat during
the mobility class I feel a little bit
[__] robots I feel a little bit uh in
your stomach or where my whole body like
you're doing something your whole body
just feels like it just goes
[Music]
um
so you shake it off a little bit I have
I bring a a watermelon protein drink 29
grams of protein you mix it with 16
ounces of water okay just to calm me
down for a little while and I drive home
on this particular day I had drank that
already but Lee I was thirsty as [__] so
I go to the gas station
by Alberto's and I get a water
and some [__] horrible taste in
Gatorade like I have been drinking
Gatorade in 20 [__] years little
sugar
so I just get Gatorade because it's a
hot day and that's what people say to do
oh yeah rehydrate yourself and you have
to electrolytes first off if anybody
knows anything about anything you got a
pedial like that [__]
by any hot given [__] day anything
like that guys I'm telling you this I
did not know this until 15 [__] years
ago don't don't quote me on this [__]
but I will tell you how I knew because
when I went to shoot The Longest Yard
the first time Goldberg saw me all right
that's the first thing he said to me the
first day when I was running
he goes I hope you're drinking pedia
like okay cause that's the only thing
that's going to bring you back
it just has like because it's for babies
right yeah so he would give me the grape
stuff now at this time it was his this
is my first encounter with Goldberg I
didn't know wrestling
I knew nothing the other guy was big at
that time which I didn't know either 19
you know 98 2000 I don't know nothing
about wrestling I had seen Goldberg on
the best damn sports show
when I did sketches for
so I knew nothing about this man I knew
nothing about professional wrestling
when I was a kid I was a fan of Chief
Chase Strongbow and [__] like that on
channel nine
on Saturday nights or Sunday mornings
whenever the [__] it came on
so now I'm on the longest shot first
[__] day of basic training that gets
us out there on the field on 400 [__]
pounds Maybe 390.
it's uh I don't know how many feet of
elevation
and I'm out there [__] around
and all of a sudden somebody says you
better get that kid oxygen I'm huffing
and puffing I hadn't done a jumping jack
in 10 [__] years I've been snorting
blow for 10 years eating fried food
living on [__] Comedy Club menus you
know I wasn't taking care of myself at
all and all so I got the [__] Longest
Yard
and my blood pressure is high on the set
and they're [__] worried and that
threatening me it's only going to be a
four-week uh contract so
this is the first day and I'm huffling
[__] puffing and thank God for one of
the trainers he said do me a favor
get them on oxygen therapy which means
that they put those two nozzles in your
nose okay and you get oxygen like a
[__] animal
and then Goldberg came over so my face
was red during we were doing the
rehearses
and he goes are you drinking he goes I
don't want you to do this [__] they
shouldn't be you got a buddy double
coming in
don't do this you're not in this type of
Shame which was it was the truth at the
time
I shouldn't have been out there I was
gonna die of a heart attack like those
football players
and he gave me a Pedialyte and he goes
uh I want you to do me a favor all I
want you to do while you're here in the
daytime is walk around in circles around
the field
so that's all I did the first two weeks
of shooting basically
I walked around the field but back to
the story he gave me Pedialyte
and I saw the wrestlers were bringing it
in by the gallons
some of the football players the other
football players were drinking Gatorade
right I've heard of pedia like when you
get sick yeah but anyway when you get
sick when you have that type of so I
don't know dick about dick I'm driving
home and all of a sudden my body's tight
enough and it's scary when you're
driving oh I'm making a left I make a
right I get onto Burbank Boulevard I'm
driving home and I feel that
in my body again I get home
it feels like that now I when I was a
young young kid I used to play
basketball all [__] day in Jersey so
between the humidity and being out there
all day all I would do is drink [__]
Iced Teas from the little Dairy thing on
top of 38th Street they used to be a
dairy thing they're like 50 feet from
the basketball courts right and if you
walk to the Derry they'd say those you
were too young no not even in a bottle
tea and then a [__] cardboard
container like that milk comes in no
like the kids are missing
this is 1975 Lee that's how iced tea
came
there was only maybe two brands of Iced
Teas there was Lipton in a can Okay
which was not bad
Lipton in a can is not bad if you doped
it up again you got to take it home put
it over ice squeeze some lemon on that
[__] a little teaspoon of real
[__] sugar bam you got yourself a
nice iced tea did you ever try Nest tea
like that's what I said like that's that
was my first introduction to tea and
that's why I can't drink anything else
because that's so sweet that's what I
thought tea was and it tasted delicious
I was like oh tea is delicious and now I
try to eat I'll give you a tea and it
tastes like dick but they got that
[__] red tea that's not bad with a
little [__] cancer sugar the blue
packages is tremendous oh wait at
Starbucks I'm making it a Starbucks you
can make it anyway back to the [__]
story Lisa I get home and I got this
thing but when I was about 13 14 they
had to take me to the doctor because my
body would stiffen up and I'd shake and
the doctor says
yo
now you're losing it
52 joints today and trying to recover I
think you were knocking on the table
anyways I'm sorry I wasn't knocking on
nothing my hands on the [__] tablet
what am I Johnny [__] doing I'm
playing Blackjack so
I [__] get home
and I get this stiff thing and I'm not
hungry at all guys
and it's about four o'clock Lee calls me
with the studio thing and I go Lehigh
going in like two hours
and I tried to lay down I couldn't fall
asleep I started getting chills
and I thought something was coming over
me I called Lee back about six Legos you
know what that nothing's back working
I called Lester cool I called us and I
go asked her we got no [__] power you
know forget it I could tell you three
hours or 20 minutes I don't want to
waste your time and make you take an
Uber for 40 bucks all the way up here I
love you I'll see you next time and I
guess me and Lee were going to do the
podcast I was gonna see how I felt I had
taken like a an Advil for pain because I
had like a migraine [__] headache and
I like that
and I kept drinking water I was not
hungry at all I didn't put any sugar in
my body
and I'm sitting there in my [__] 6
30. I'm talking to my wife I got a
hooded sweatshirt on
in my living room with jeans a blanket
and a [__] pillow on top meanwhile
it's so hot outside that the power went
out oh my [__] God I am shaking
[__] cold
finally I feel something in my stomach
I walk to the [__] door
I open it and I just look head over and
I stick my finger down my throat and
there it comes out because I know when
it's time to stick your finger down what
do you no you didn't tell me this why do
you stick your finger down here because
why [__] play the game it's sitting
there you could feel it I'm not your
[__] you can't [__] feel it that
you have something that's stuck there
you're burping it you're burping it now
I'm not burping food I'm burping like an
acid which I don't [__] acids I never
burped that [__] that Gatorade was
horrible so that was part of the burp
also you know you know I was gonna say
this the other day I was wondering if
maybe the cold water made you throw up
because a couple of times like when I've
been too high on Edibles no if I drink
it makes me throw up it doesn't make you
shove it like that and give you a
[__] feel oh no I know so I started
barfing in the middle of the barf boom I
fart and it's pure [__]
thank God I had the pants on the
underwear on some [__] Jujitsu so I
went in the shower
came out now we all know it's official
I'm [__] sick
I call Leah say the podcast is off I'm
about to get sicker I go back outside
Lee you should have heard it hitting the
leaves on the floor
was I kind of had a pot of water and
just thrown it over and it was like
I hadn't eaten anything solid all day I
tell you guys I eat a yogurt I drink
almond milk smoothie for breakfast and
it's even worse when it's all liquid I
didn't even have a protein shake that
day I had nothing I went up to Jujitsu
on the [__] whatever because I put a
half a banana in it for the carbs that
was it
I went to [__] Jiu Jitsu next thing
you know guys by eight o'clock
I was like 101 my wife had the [__]
white tiles on my head
you know I tried to lay down then I [__]
to bed
on the way to the bathroom to puke
I [__] a little piece on the bed and I'm
I'm honest with you guys because well
you want me to tell you that you know
this is how sick I [__] was at nine
o'clock at night
so I went through one pair of jeans and
three pair of shorts
but the best was I ran outside and I had
shorts on with no underwear on and I
puked and a little piece of [__] went
out of my ass and land on the porch
exactly where I stand x marks the spot
where I stand and do the [__] morning
periscope
I hadn't even known since I went back
there at night to puke again I called my
wife on so I go look at this she goes oh
my God how embarrassing the next day we
had to Chisel it off I called late we
had to Chisel this [__] thing off
until the next morning because when I do
I'm sick my wife didn't want to [__]
see it I already [__] the bed [__]
repair [__] shorts the toilet I mean
it was a [__] nightmare Lee oh my God
so now I'm up all [__] night guys
tremendous 12 o'clock I'm sleeping two
hour intervals and waking up to [__] and
puke
do our intervals to wake up to go block
and I either run to the toilet or I have
patience I hate puking in [__]
toilets you know what man how many years
am I going to be my toilet I started my
life puking outside in the weeds when I
was a drunk kid then I went inside the
toilets now it's been 30 years until
it's I'm done I want to puke back
outside the jungle Where I Belong so I
go out to the balcony I just barf listen
to me my neighbor downstairs the people
downstairs have like a bunch
[Laughter]
you got a bunch of like [__] hidden and
they got a kid's pool and thoughtmen to
protect it from the [__] brain you
know I puked on that kid's pool maybe 18
times and it's right next to a window I
can't believe she heard it I'm telling
you it's like I was taking pieces at
at two in the [__] morning
it's like I was taking pieces
of
the [__]
pork chops
and uh
and putting it together I'm not I'm on
the podcast Andrew Dice Clay calling in
[__] live he's gonna be at the Coney
Island Amphitheater July [__] 30th
Jim Florentine my sister Eleanor
Kerrigan and [__] Wheels Parisi if
you don't go I don't want you talking to
me ever again tell them Andrew
you're [__] on [__] tell him
Asbury Park that's how connected we are
you just happened to [__] call and I
said you were supposed to be on tonight
but things happen so God bless you if
you don't go to the call he's back in
[__] Brooklyn [__] this is big
this is bigger than [__] Hillary
Clinton getting elected [__] that little
Affair this is Andrew Dice Clay coming
back a [__] comedy hero do you
understand me most people don't even get
a chance to do it [__] half a time
this guy's coming back with a [__]
medal and then some he's coming back
with dead Vietnamese is on a [__]
chain so
foreign
I'm glad I called I'm glad I needed to
laugh I've been so [__] up all week
well you're [__] ready to go I love
that you're in Coney Island
that's why I texted you the other day
like you were texting me like what time
was it like two in the morning I was
puking my brains off I was sick to death
I had the glasses on the diarrhea
they texted me I was
I was so bad I could tell when you said
something about Matt Dillon I was
laughing in all my agony
other than text ladies and gentlemen
um
if I saw it the next day
you know and I'll go
although I said
why don't you get crazy [__]
[__] where you at
telling my son got me all [__] I
I'm gonna [__]
[__] for Pokemon
oh my God people are so [__] stupid
something that means balls is All Humans
that's what I was texting you
oh [__] Joey
Joey I'm here
so when you're texting me you're gonna
picture this I'm sitting in this
this you know how like you know in your
bathroom or something I have like a
pocket door on the toilet
and and we painted the room like there's
blood red the toilet room
the late night smoke out room that you
could blow the smoke out the window
while you sit on the floor in the
Backwoods and you're trying to call me
and text me and I'm still
getting mine you know and all I'm doing
for whatever reason is thinking about
[__] at that hour
you know and you're texting me about the
podcast
that morning let me tell you something I
was I was as sick as a [__] dog that
night
oh puking [__] I was just telling them
on the show why I had to cancel the show
Monday night
first time ever
oh no no now I'm still a little queasy I
haven't barf the [__] myself today
so we're halfway there but I'm by
tomorrow I'll be fine I'll be back to
100 so
[Music]
in [__] Philly that's number one oh
Philly was great Philadelphia is always
the [__]
Chef what was it a comedy
you know
he goes did you ever try to follow Joe
Diaz and I go well that would be kind of
stupid you know he goes he's a [__]
monster up there
just like Bella's blow out
you know when you have him with you you
know because I didn't even know if I
could go on after that you know so so
that's a great compliment because I I
love bill
yeah but I know what you can
do it's not like I haven't seen it you
know what I mean hey man you [__]
started it for me so
I can shovel up there and you know me I
have no problem giving guys
and you know I know your fans listen and
the same nice tits and ass because I
never kissed ass in my life to anybody
but when a guy is great
and he's [__] great
then it's it's really nice to know that
there was some real
Politically
Incorrect [__] that don't
listen to a [__] thing when it comes
to that stand up and you just do it the
way you've been doing it from the day I
met you you know and that and that's
then that's what makes for a comedian
because if we can't do it the way we do
it what the [__] is comedy ever going to
be again
you know what I mean you understand that
first of all thank you and no no I
believe it I believe it
select and you're going nowhere
uh I love you
I'll call you when I finish it and
uh
oh my God I'm still I'm just as stoned
as you a Monday night
right now look I know I'm going into
Brooklyn the atmosphere is going to be
fantastic it's gonna be a fantastic
[__] [__] child
I didn't even call you I didn't even
know you're on the air now so it's great
they are and I and I I do want the fans
to know they're going to walk out of
that [__] Amphitheater shaking their
heads though and I never seen nothing
like that
it's what I like to bring to the public
you know if they're paying for the
[__] ticket I want them to walk out
happy and go the greatest show just the
greatest [__] show and that's what I
like to bring to the table some psych to
go back to Brooklyn she's a friend see
the family see the fans
but honestly I I just called you to tell
you that you know what you do for me
with the podcast and the way you pump me
you're just aces in my [__] book
that's it amen you took me out of the
darkest hole in my life
when I saw you [__] do those jokes
yeah we move on my brother
and again what you could do take the
higher cash and just go down the road
you've gone down and I'm proud of the
success you [__] became that's what
makes me happy you didn't just disappear
you wanted a comedy store guy with a big
mouth that disappeared in two years is
stuck with it and now you're a major
[__] comic in this world and that's
something
they're meant to be said for that
for that I encourage that [__]
you know I wouldn't care if she came on
in front of me and just destroyed the
crowd that's the way it should be with
anybody either co-head lying or opening
to you just go out there and murder
these [__] give them their
money's worth
when a very stressed out uptight [__]
[__] guys like us that make it a
little easier for people to go day to
[__] day and that's the bottom
[__] line
I love you [__] I'll call you back
with all my heart okay okay my all-time
favorite the all-time heavyweight
Saturday night Coney Island he's back in
Brooklyn I love you Andrew
that was crazy guys that was just pure
uh he just called out of the whim and I
just wanted to let you guys know that
he's a good dude man and I appreciate
his uh
his uh compliments and his uh
encouragement over the years guys it's
nice that
you know
I've been getting a lot of emails this
week
I wanted to talk to you about this
league because it's so [__] important
in life
and we don't get it
we really do not get it
and I cannot believe people who have
been following the podcast people who
have been emailing with me people who
follow comedy in general
people who will sing behind the curtain
email me this week that listen I've done
some [__] up [__] on the show you know
we've gotten emails about you getting
farts in the face
you know things that I've said or people
disagree
but this week I looked at the emails one
day and they were astronomical
for like a one day it was like 18 one
day Jesus then it was like 13 the other
on Gmail so I can't imagine this is
church Gmail I can't imagine what's on
Beauty and the Beast you know
you know some emails were about
addiction this do you know what these
were about
that I can't [__] believe that they
didn't put you all over the Oddball
Festival
I mean people like questioning me like
what the [__] was wrong with me why did
I agree to that they didn't even black
out my name
you know and
I couldn't believe it I answered the
emails back as honestly as I could be I
was not angry at nobody I did not attack
anybody nothing like this the emails
were basically I had to take my time for
this and this was the morning
after
no this is the morning before I went to
jiu jitsu okay the Sunday morning I
looked at the computer and that's when I
got the 12 months what the [__] is this
and people like hey man I can't believe
that you're only hosting
at the Oddball festival and it was like
people trying to make me feel bad
about taking a job that maybe I don't
know maybe I'm overqualified for
I don't [__] know I got a call and
they asked me if I'm interested in doing
Oddball fast my agent says I wouldn't do
it for that price
but maybe I can get you this price would
you be interested
and I go if you think that's whatever
you think is fair I'll do you're my
agent he went back and he got me a
little bit more he didn't get me the
magical number but he got me different
props and that helped
so I thought about it at first guys I'm
a [__] old man guys it's five [__]
days of traveling you know it's roughing
it up I haven't roughed it up in 10
years Lee
you know what I'm saying I've been doing
comedy very avant-garde same city every
for the whole weekend yeah you know I
haven't roughed it up and uh
15 [__] years you know when you do uh
Tuesday and Wednesday somewhere Thursday
Friday Saturday somewhere then Sunday
eight hours out of that [__] town
so
I agreed to it I said sure I'll do it
it's it's
to me
it was a good lineup I knew it was
Gabriel I knew it was Sebastian I know
it's Tom Segura I think it's Bert
Kreischer I know it's the girl that's
been on the podcast that you like a lot
that we both like a lot the writer
um Sarah Tiana oh right yeah absolutely
so I got a nice lineup why would I be
the guy I couldn't believe I had to
break this down to people that for once
in my life I get to work with my friends
not only that Gabe invited me on this
bus so I just saved on plane tickets in
between the three [__] cities I'm
gonna take the red eye with him they're
gonna pick us up
take us to the hotel sleep all day and
then we leave Friday morning for Tampa
on the bus we get there about 11 or 12.
we spend the day in Tampa we do Tampa we
get on the [__] bus and drive all
[__] night we get to Indy get on the
bus
whatever and then we uh we fly out of
Indianapolis now I'm pretty honored to
[__] through that guys you know why
because nobody's ever invited me to dick
yeah it must be it must feel great and
then you've spoken before about like
people not taking I don't wanna I don't
want that kind of job
this is a great tour
that who knows maybe you are
overqualified technically to host but
hosting
that you get they get to see you all
night
they only see each comic for like 15
minutes you're gonna go up there five
six times they're gonna see you we gotta
do it from the beginning yeah and 10
after the intermission okay and then
bring them up yeah but yeah and then
you're gonna you're gonna joke around
with them it's uh Brody did it I will
not the only Oddball I ever went to in
Irvine and Paul and I still talk and I
told Brody on the podcast I said you
were out of that big headliner names we
oh we still talk about Brody because you
come out you're you're interacting with
them months it's gonna be fun you're
gonna really like no I love all that
[__] so [__] them but I couldn't believe
people were angry at me for hosting like
you should have [__] headlined they
were actually attacking some people on
Twitter oh Jesus like [__] you you know
and I'm like Jesus Christ guys I made
the decision because I thought it was
just nice enough that they thought of me
the guys that picked those tours they
have so many people to deal with I don't
know what happened I I heard rumors in
the beginning that they had all these
big names
so something must have happened they
called me they asked and I took the
[__] job now
in my world
I could have been Joe bananas and said
[__] you give me a co-head landing spot
and give me this type of money
shell and they would have responded
maybe no
maybe yes
but you know what man
for me these [__] 17 years out here
for 12 of those years nobody talked to
me
nobody talked to me yeah Adam Sandler
put me in movies and [__] Remy and
[__] like that but comically nobody
[__] talked to me and I gotta tell
you something if you listen to those
first couple CDs you wouldn't talk to me
either so I can't blame it either on
that too but this is a journey
this is why it's good to get those CDs
and go wow that's what happens if you
stick life out sometimes
but in my world
I've never been invited to Montreal I've
never been invited to all the [__]
festivals how many comedy festivals they
have every weekly 22 yeah when do they
when do they call Uncle Joey for a
[__] Festival not that I would go
because I'm busy with other things and
[__] no but it's nice to be invited no
it's like today listen man I always get
put in these [__] predicaments
there's this thing going on in my
hometown
okay okay he died on 9 11. I never knew
the young man but everybody says he's a
sweetheart of a kid and it was a [__]
shame and they listen everybody who died
on 9 11.
a [__] shape
but that's not what this is about
they always hit me up in August and they
always say
hey just in case if you're going to be
in the area drop in and do the [__]
benefit
and every year I say to them no I'm not
going to be in the [__] area and
every year this is going on for six
years now seven years hey if you're
gonna be in the area why don't you drop
by
because I don't live in the [__] area
one of my closest friends in the [__]
world
closest friends from [__] fifth grade
him and his brother Sergio he sends me a
note again because we've been talking a
lot lately I think it was Mylene
Mooney's mother Eileen when he was a kid
we went to a girl who went to school
with my freshman year she was a little
older than me
not the best looking girl in the world
but the personality of a [__] star
and you know what she always had
boyfriends and [__] like that
and one night she went out with this
jealous dude she was dating this jealous
dude and she went out with another dude
and after the dude dropped her off to do
Cam and shot it and killed
and killed and there was a shame it was
really sad and she was a good lady she
left a little boy
so it was her mother who contacted
Carlos and and I said I said listen tell
him Mrs Mooney I loved Eileen that was
her name Eileen Mooney but say look let
me break it down to you again I'm 50
[__] three I do two podcasts a week I
do this I do this I do this I do this
I'm trying to do this I'm trying to do
that
I just don't live in the neighborhood
it's an hour drive to the [__]
airport in the park an hour at the
airport in a six hour flight and then
the same coming [__] back that's 16
hours now
we also have a dilemma CAA you know I
just can't do a gig and advertise it
they have to commission and I signed the
contract
if not they get sued or I get sued or
it's a [__] nightmare which means I
just can't walk into a bar and say Hey I
want to do a show here and this is what
like let's say
let's say I'm working Gotham okay I have
a 90 day cloth
do you follow me for what Gotham no 90
days for what I can't play in that area
got it now
I would be a [__] idiot to play in
that area
because I would lose Gotham
and I have a good relationship with him
so to me it's more than about the Clause
I have a great relationship with a guy
who owns got him I just spoke to him
last week I just called him to check in
and he called me right back and we spoke
about this and that whatever the [__]
you know me it's Monday you got to
brighten somebody's [__] there
so
if I do a benefit you gotta say I'm
gonna be there and charge money for the
tickets
I don't get any of the money I don't
care about that
what I care about is that CAA wants
their Commission
do you see what I'm saying they don't
care about a benefit they don't care
about benefits of missing legs or people
getting blown up in Iran they don't give
a [__] about nothing dead Jews dog they
don't give a [__] they don't give a [__]
they want their ten percent so not only
that the guy from New York right it's
going to call CA and said me and Joey
had a great relationship I just seen an
ad in the [__] paper
that Joe is doing a benefit
he's taking money out of my [__] club
do you see how it works so it's more
it's like a gentleman's agreement man
why would I bite the [__] hand that
feeds
is it is it weird that you are like it's
an entertaining entertainment as a job
like but it's it's listen there's some
people I don't give a Frenchman's [__]
about right there's some people that I
want to go back there and let the club
on fire and drive a truck line I don't
give a [__] but there's certain people
that I have a great relationship from
we've we've become not even business
friends we've become friends on the side
we talk it's not really even about the
money anymore
it's places I like to work it's the
freedoms they give me and what they let
me do and what I do they give me a job I
give them a job we both do it we shake
hands we get a check
so them and I work me and Philly work me
and buffalo work
me and uh you know San Jose work me and
the punch line in Sacramento we [__]
Jive Jack me and the punchline in San
Francisco I would live in the basement
if I could at the San Francisco punch
line we Jive they don't mean a check to
me when I go up there I'm happy to see
the manager I'm happy to see that
waitress I'm happy to see the wait staff
you know what I'm saying even though the
wings are shitty you know I eat the
[__] Wings to talk to the Mexican
cook in the back
you know it's an experience for me an
extra experience for me where for them
it's one for me when I go to the
Minnesota Club up in the mall he's not
there but he always sends regards in a
gift package and he puts a little extra
in the [__] check for me and he
leaves me a [__] message on Monday
morning that means the world to me he's
running three [__] clubs you
understand me so I jive with that
[__] so when you call me and say
you're putting together an All-Star
[__] lineup
and uh and you want me to be on the tour
but I gotta [__] on this relationship I
can't do it
I can't do it because I have a
relationship with that guy
he started with me when nobody gave me a
shot he believed in me right you know
how many [__] clubs Justin called for
me in the beginning a lot
the only people gave me chances not many
not many people said straight up [__]
no
now some of them have called back and
that's okay because they called back
with
head down and a check in their hand you
understand me you know I'm a Jew at
heart you follow me so don't come to me
with a frown and you head down and
nothing in your hand now you got to look
down and give me a little extra check
and say dog we're sorry
somewhere along the line we misjudged
each other let's put it behind you I
gave you a little extra yeah would that
take that take care of things for a
while take a look at the number I gave
you yes and you know I never talked
money to me it's like talk to me a 200
bonus
means the world just the word bone it's
just it's a bonus what
what yeah what the
what episode a thousand drinks
you know the guy that owns the Cleveland
room okay one time I went there he gave
me you know like a you know 600 more
just because somebody bought champagne
he didn't have to do that
he's gonna have to do that
but you'll never forget it never never
again in fact I kept his email called
him sent him a Christmas card you got to
send them all Acres I said no dog I do
comedy clubs the same way I said do this
[__] when I get out of there I send a
thank you card
to who the general manager and the staff
enjoy the Stars enjoy the cheaper choose
enjoy the reefer that's it it's the same
business as before I'm still a Salesman
so I still got to take my relationships
and [__] whatever when I go there I
tell them my boundaries they tell me
their boundaries and I adhere to them
you know but if you let me know you're
in your corner I went to a club once in
the Chicago area where I felt
uncomfortable from A to Z you're a
carpenter you walk into somebody's
[__] house
okay first off they don't want to pay
you what you're [__] worth
okay from the minute you walk in there
they're watching you like you're a
[__] thief I've been with [__]
people who I've worked as a carpenter's
Helper and I remember going into places
where people treated them like [__] and
telling me in the truck you know what
man I gave these people 120 off because
they were my neighbors look how they
[__] treat me I should have kept them
120 it would have been worth it now
they're making me sweep and take out the
[__] garbage and whatever so you know
what man even at that time when they
were [__] robbing me the headline
right I went home and made a decision
I'll never [__] go there this guy
puts an offer for me every [__] year
because he never took care of me he was
never nice to me he kept judging me he
wouldn't let me come out the music
so it's the same [__] thing Lee
duh
I think it's the thing with anyone
anyone who treats you like [__] I love I
love being able to not I don't
necessarily want to treat them like [__]
maybe part of me does but it's nice just
to let them just like ever since I've
been out here I've had like four or five
people from high school email me either
one take it on the TV show I was working
on or after this wanted to go to a show
or something
and it I don't know I was like I didn't
say it but I was like yeah maybe you
should like want like where were you in
high school like why why am I now so
like why do you not want to call me so I
was like yeah [__] you no and I like
these people you know I would if that
like I told callers I said give him my
number
and tell her to call me in February
I'll tell her what I need
um but I also tell her what she can and
she can't do
so I'm not I'm gonna go to New York in
September this year okay but next year
I'm going the week before Thanksgiving I
haven't been to New York in the winter a
long time and I want to take my family
so February November is okay that's a
long enough period well no if I do it in
September right I could do it November
you know what I'm saying and nobody has
to know you know my friend has a bar my
teacher has a bar he busts my chops all
the time what are they gonna do comedy I
really can't
because he really can't advertise it he
could say he's having a comedy show
but you really can't advertise it
uh is this is so is that why people
can't advertise sometimes they say like
special guests or
I never knew that you know I work Vegas
I love the South Point Casino
but I also work those things with Joe
because he knows those things give me
exposure and they bring 10 more people
to the shows every time I do it
so it works for all of us it's not like
I'm doing a show at a bar
charging 10 bucks
right and taking money out of his pocket
the South Point Casino they do a thing
called Dirty at 12 30.
time I go YC and they contact me to do
it they don't understand why I don't
want to do it because I'm there on a
Friday night and on a Saturday night and
then they want you to do a free show on
Friday then if I do a free show nobody
will come to the show on Saturday night
that was proven the first time I did it
second time I did hit on me dog how many
he can't major the second time I did it
I left the casino floor at 10 and the
next night Saturday it was [__]
packed
then the third time we shot the special
but if you think about the mathematics
on it that's why I didn't do it and they
get mad at me that I don't do the dirty
at 12 30. I won't because you want the
[__] numbers so I can't compete with
myself
right that means I'm compete with myself
I can't compete with myself so there's a
business part of this that a lot of
people don't understand and people get
[__] pissed off
like a comedian
contacted me that I was dear friends
with 20 years ago and now he lives in
Texas okay and he contacted me to do a
gig
at like a bar you know in
this town that I work pretty much often
I haven't hit him back that I couldn't
do it because I worked that club and I
have a good relationship with them and
he proceeded to tell me how they were
thieves this and this and this this and
this and this they did that now I know
this [__] mutt of a comic and this
guy robbed the [__] uh ink out of
your pen I'm saying he's one of those
[__] he'll take your last
feather
so you know I just said listen I
understand how you feel but
I have a business obligation and I can't
[__] abide through it and then he
wrote me back again that what the [__]
happened to me nothing happened to me I
can't do your [__] bar you know Club
Amazon you know one of those [__]
dance halls or some [__] with low riders
or whatever the [__] that is I can't
[__] do that [__] don't stop me in
those [__] places at this age
so you know he could he couldn't
understand that he had to go through my
age I go if you want to book me there
you have to go through my [__] Agent
Man
if not I just get caused Heat
it's just unnecessary heat that I gotta
take for somebody I don't want to take
that so I try to do everything through
that now
the only thing I don't do to them is the
local rooms around here and the Chinese
restaurant up there
but pretty soon I can't do that Chinese
restaurant
because the Improv is opening up Oxnard
dude like so do these comedy clubs have
like territories almost it's kind of
it's very interesting it's not that they
have territories it's that they have
listen there's two clubs in Minneapolis
okay they have two very popular Club
Acme club which is a great club and I'm
just throwing out clubs to people and
the Minneapolis Club I worked at the
Mall of America guy's a great guy from
Canada there's two clubs there okay the
one guy is run by a sweetheart Acme you
know what I showcased there let me tell
you something I didn't do bad but I
could tell I wasn't the style of Comedy
was I mad no I looked at the lineup
couldn't see myself on that lineup all
brilliant comics but not comedians like
me except maybe two of them
Mall of America they have more
mainstream people they give more people
shots
blah blah blah blah blah blah in Florida
15 years ago there was a Miami Improv
and there was a club in Davie
okay you know they would get pissed at
you in those days today they're partners
but 20 years ago you had to work one or
the other but to be honest with you the
people that worked The Improv wouldn't
have really worked that show in club and
Davey
they would only book first comedians now
so it didn't really [__] matter do
you understand me but look at a
situation like Tempe Arizona right now
okay what's going on there five comedy
clubs in one city one city damn
so you've got
celebrity live in Phoenix okay you've
got
the club the coke little the [__]
dude owns then you got the Chicago
[__] little Hitler dude he owns a
club and then you've got Tempe Improv
you got the House of Comedy and you got
the [__] Laugh Factory my bad
six comedy clubs in the Phoenix Metro
[__] area
that's like putting six Subway
sandwiches in three blocks and giving
everybody [__] five dollars you
understand me you're gonna create
[__] chaos that it's you can't feed
six comedy clubs
so you got Paul Rodriguez at one club
The Improv they're no [__] Geniuses
don't put [__] Joe Diaz and Tempe in
February and try to put them back and
[__] in Phoenix and [__] July if
you let him if you let them that's what
they do
that's their philosophy which I will not
I stay at Tempe you know why because
I've been going to Tempe since 98. even
though the owner is dead and gone like
creepy died guy rests peace what's his
name [__] uh
whatever his [__] name is that creepy
dude about me and then 98. they [__]
closed the club they shot the owner the
creepy dude died in [__] Chicago and
they closed the club The Improv brought
it back and now it's open so they come
they opened up a club in two competing
cities they compete against themselves
The Improv you know that right with
Liberty Lines yeah so they have Levity
Live in the 10 p.m isn't Levity Live
huge huge 600 seats you could have the
[__] circus in there
so and Tempe is not a [__] small
place either no so you got five comedy
clubs in this area fighting for the same
[__] nickel dodging it out drawing
[__] bullets at themselves and then
you got Buffalo helium
going to the bank like Tony Montana
every [__] week
because they're the only game in town
because it's the only game in town you
go to Omaha Funny Bone only game in town
so but back to your like not a good
relationship so you're in Phoenix let's
say you didn't have that relationship
with the champion Prof but you just
always trying to pick one rather than
going from each one to each one just so
you can maybe each year build a
relationship like is that important
I'd rather build a relationship at the
same [__] club with people okay if I
know the drinks are good there's a
couple clubs I went there in the last
six eight months
that
food sucked
The Green Room sucked
they had no respect for Comics but in a
fake way
she reminded me of somebody that I
didn't like that I also saw behind the
curtain in life that had to do with
comedy
and for some reason I never worked there
again
when I was there that Saturday night
first show I I knew I was never going
back to that club
I'm one of those guys and I knew and I
said to myself the only thing that'll
make me come back here
is when I saw my check and sure enough
it was lighter than [__]
I'm gonna have to come back and look at
my contract and it was a horrible
[__] deal
but the fact that she didn't even raise
a hand and go here's a yardstick
buy yourself a steak when you get back
to [__] L.A
and how the whole situation worked out
like I've just seen it a couple times
Lee
I've seen it a couple times but
I've also had
the weirdest I had the weirdest weirdest
weirdest situation happened this year
now
last year you know there's a lot of
comics that don't like the Improv chain
of all the [__] people I've had
problems with in comedy that didn't like
me one guy grew a relationship was the
guy that first started me in the dirty
showing Bray
well guess what that guy Rose in the
ranks
so me and him started that room together
he taught me how to [__] do marketing
for comedy clubs in a lot of ways
he said to for me to do a certain thing
and I added my twist to it
and that brand room became successful
that's how all this started with brand
if you really want to get down to it it
was that one time a month in prayer
building that little first 300 people
that would come down and watch Yoshi get
[__] up and watch Martin Moreno and
watch Ricky Cruz and what's just Johnny
Rock and watch just a bunch of fun guys
we would just have a fun
[__] time once a [__] month you
know Drive the bray in a rush smoke dope
we would cut banana bread and put it in
the back you remember that right I was I
think I came right after that you picked
the CD then yeah yeah that's where we
taped the enthusias yeah I mean you know
we just
that's where it really solidified so
while we were there he grew
and he grew again and he grew again
well you know what man I booked one of
his clubs
and I had to cancel because of a movie
or because of Marin or something
something happened I had to cancel
and I went back the next year and you
know what man I went up there for
[__] terrible terrible terrible money
now I could have done two things
I could have raised my hand and canceled
it again
or I could have had my agent call back
and we go renegotiate
I thought about the situation for a
minute and I go you know what
I agreed to this I canceled I profited
on the movie now I gotta what's the line
you hate from Pink Floyd oh uh reap what
you sell I gotta reap what I saw so
guess what I went up there and I did
good on stage I worked as hard as I
could and satellite before I got on
stage
the manager comes and he goes hey man
you got a call in the office and I went
to the office and it was that guy from
Brett
and he goes hey man I talked to the
[__] club and I looked at the numbers
I'm giving you a bonus
because you stood up to your deal thank
you very much and I'm going to give you
a bonus in all the other clubs for you
sticking to your [__] deal I didn't
say a word Lee
I could have been a scumbag and had them
call up and bumped them for what the
extra nickel
the extra 850.
and it's so short it would have been
short-sighted like you know you agreed
to something now you're going to do it
you were short-sighted you canceled it's
always weird when people ask for money I
never won like that's
ah
it's awkward
in only you live and learn and as a
business owner
you live and [__] learn you know you
just uh living and learning I gotta
explain something to you I'm
I got sick before Andrew called I got
sick guys
so what happened Tuesday was I didn't
sleep all night Monday night
I [__] you know was half in a coma
every two hours I'd sleep I'd have to
get up underwear change
Short Change you know meanwhile I'm
smoking dope though you know when you're
smoking dope I was smoking dope to calm
me down it would calm me down I would be
out there sweating profusely with the
warm-up
every time I got sickly I would lose
three pounds and just body sweat oh my
God it was [__] horrendous
but what was I talking about the only
one little [__] dog you were sick and
Tuesday and I was supposed to do
the agostinos what's the name of it ah
the Black Horse Tavern I think the Black
Horse Tavern up in Reseda which he had
been working on for like two months and
he put a nice line up together yeah I
called him at lunch time and I said
listen I'm gonna go to the doctor to see
what the [__] going on here
uh I'll call you back afterward if I
feel bad I promise you I'll go up there
if not I'll go up there next Tuesday he
took it like a man
but meanwhile you called me
and you're all excited telling me I'm
going up there the the time I'm gonna go
drink a beer and I was happy I'm like
[__] look at Lee hanging out with
young kids instead of some old [__]
next thing you know
I'm looking at my Twitter I'm sitting
there shivering you know and in between
one of the Shivers I look at my Twitter
and I see this D'Agostino post and it's
a picture of me him
a bunch of other guys but one of the
pictures is Lee giggling so I say to
myself
I wouldn't have Lisa to go up there and
[__] do a raffle I didn't know what
the [__] you were going to do I thought
they were going to do a raffle or
something like that
and the next thing you know
I gotta he calls me back last night you
were liking this euphoric state
and I was a little still [__] up last
night we talked to like one or something
because I couldn't fall back to sleep
last night I had slept all [__] day
in and out
and then this morning the Agostino calls
me tells you how you went up on stage
with your [__] phone you had you
wrote jokes and [__] what's getting over
you well I had no idea okay so
D'Agostino called me like a month ago I
was just say I'm doing the show now
Jesus Christ
so I'm doing the show now and it's your
birthday right around the same time why
don't you come up and just and hang out
so I said okay
he said maybe maybe you'll come on and
host with me like you'll come on and
introduce you'll come on and say hi at
the beginning of the show
so then he texted me yesterday I was
like are you still coming because Joey's
not feeling well I was like yeah I'll
come he's like okay and then he's a
called me or texted me I was like so how
many how long do you want to do or like
what do you want to do and I was like I
don't know
and he said well if you want to do
comedy you can so I was I was like why
not and uh I worked on like three or
four premises I didn't have jokes
written out
and I think I did like two and a half
minutes Steve Simone recorded it audio
so I haven't even though it was terrible
but I don't know it was fun it was uh I
because I if you remember because Matt
Voltron was there and Matt Voltron was
on that one live podcast we did down at
Long Beach where you got me [__] up on
the way down to Long Beach so by the
time I was introducing people I was
super stoned they were terrible that
audience they were [__] Frozen yeah
like that was like the last time I'd
been been on stage and that was like bad
so I was nervous and I got a couple
Giggles it was a it was an interesting
experience
I don't know if I'd ever do it again how
many people were there
it was full I'd say close to 30 or 40
maybe maybe more I'm bad at that though
it looked pretty full
and what did you feel while you were up
there
I didn't like the first couple times
like I used to introduce you at the ice
house or stuff like that I would
I get very nervous when I start talking
fast like I can't catch my breath
my heart starts racing
and from doing
the live podcast and I introduced you at
the special
that's kind of gone away a little bit I
was still a little nervous
but it was also it was also kind of nice
because I know there was one person
there who who tweeted me I think his
name was Eddie who came because he saw
and he was very nice but other than that
no one knew me so that was pretty
exciting look that's because everyone
asks me even though he's been on the
phone last time he was here he told me
to do it
I honestly don't think it's what I want
to do with my life
but I've thought about going to open
mics but I don't wanna
okay I thought about maybe the haha but
D'Agostino used to work there and so I
couldn't do I didn't want to go
somewhere where someone would know me so
then there's the the store The Improv
and the Laugh Factory that's I don't
ever want to go anywhere where you go
and so I would I had no idea where to go
so but now that Diego is doing this
every Tuesday
it could be kind of fun it was It was a
it was The Accidental diagostino said I
had good premises so that was
interesting
you know man
could be really good at something
sometimes you got to be good at a couple
things or know about a couple things is
what I'm trying to say okay Larry
David's a great writer but every once in
a while he gets a win Point 30 days and
he goes to the Laugh Factory every night
he gets on stage
excuse me I think Greg Garcia has gotten
on stage
it's a different
you know sometimes you do Jiu Jitsu and
you take a couple Judo classes
and it makes you understand what you're
doing a little better
okay I see what you're saying sometimes
you're a karate dude you know GSB was an
MMA guy and also in the train he started
going to Pacquiao this guy
sometimes by learning a different
discipline it makes you learn more of
what you know right you know when I
lived in Colorado I always noticed how
there was always framers
or we just frame houses you know this
team of guys I kept working I worked for
an electrician
so the framers will come in
and then I would drill the holes and run
some of the wire and then the [__] uh
sheetrockers are coming and then as is
the ceiling and then we we put run the
wire in the ceiling for the lights and
then the sheetrockers would seal up and
then we'd come back and do the fixtures
and then the painters would come and
paint there's a system to everything
right okay but there was a crew of guys
that would come in and they'd [__]
just ring
and I became friends with the foreman it
was a two-man crew it was a company but
they had two Crews okay and they had
worked together for years and they could
come in and frame these houses
amount of time yeah I don't know what
the exact stuff was there were three
guys cutting and one guy yelling and
[__] it was a great system
but
um I asked him once why don't you guys
bid the block you know
the drywall in English because you can't
you have to you know just do the drywall
and on one of the jobs these guys [__]
up a bunch of stuff
and I always even as a 19 year old kid
because that's how old I was when I was
doing that I go these guys would have
known and I know this conversation's
confusing
they [__] up it had to be every 16
inches each piece of wood that's how you
know or something and somebody was high
and they did the difference of the
plywood guys had to come back and take
the plywood off
so I always thought to myself that day
why don't the [__] plywood guys know
what the [__] the frame isn't doing
which tattoo corner but why doesn't
everybody know what everybody's doing
okay you know what I'm saying like just
because you're a carpenter listen no
doesn't mean you can't know a little bit
of [__] Plumbing you know just to
really learn what the [__] it did if I'm
saying I don't even know if I'm making
sense here I think you are but I think
you're also well because yeah you have
to know it would be good to know like
for example a lot of editors become
directors because when they're editing
they're like oh I need this shot he
needs this shot I need this so they they
understand where the other side is
coming from I think though it's kind of
interesting with the house though
because it's kind of like an assembly
line everyone just does their one thing
so
like you're not telling me to go become
not to to quit the podcast and go head
deep into comedy listen but to just
you're 28 years old
I'm not telling you to do nothing but
smoke pot and eat [__] and go to the
gym every day that's all the advice
you're gonna get from me whether you're
my son or not you know what I'm saying
I all I want to do is be happy I want
you to be eating some ass every night or
three four nights a week I want you to
lift weights I want you to write your
goals and I want you to do what the [__]
you want to do but here you are here you
are a young kid email me videos boom
runs podcast number 400.
yeah I've been talking to you lately now
listen man you know I don't like the
whole fat shaming thing you know I don't
like the [__] fat damn anything
because if your friends like it they'll
tell you you're a fat [__]
absolutely you can't keep wearing those
sandals you feed a 400 [__] pounds a
piece you can't keep wearing them you're
scaring [__] people boys are not
talking to us you have to say
different things I don't even know where
the [__] I'm going with this
but
we started doing this podcast and the
first couple of times you said you
didn't even want to talk on the [__]
podcast
so now 400 podcasts later not only are
you talking you're a major contributor
in this [__] thing because I can't
sit here and talk to myself because I
would lose my mind so your major
contributor to this thing I've told you
time and time again I'm not in business
to blow smoke up nobody's ass I don't
like I'm gonna blow smoke up my ass I
know exactly what I'm doing but right
now you're learning a business you ever
have people you ever get to you ever
watch TV or you're in your job there's a
[__] who yells here and he says
I've been doing this for 40 years and
you walk away and call that guy a loser
let me tell you something my friend
you know you can't imagine doing
something for 40 [__] years but I'll
tell you what
I've been doing this for 25. I've been
podcasting to you for five
it all mix
it all mixed it all adds up it all adds
up so when I yell at you one day and I
go I've been doing this for 40 years
it's because a 50 of the people when
they quit already somewhere along the
line and B I'm the first guy to [__] at
people when you're an actor and also
like on an audition I see you behind the
camera pisses me off a lot of a couple
things pissed me off but then the truth
comes out I'm talking about the people
who I had a friend here in town that he
was a [__] TV repairman or whatever
the [__] he was but one day he went to a
party he smoked some dope and he wanted
to become a producer he couldn't wait to
say the [__] word producer he would
say the word producer all [__] day
long
so for years he mucked around for no dog
being associate producers which means
what pick up garbage hold the Rope
tell that guy to stand there you know
what I'm saying [__] like that so he
would tell everybody he was a [__]
producer
I was on the set of The Longest Yard one
day and I was talking to one of the
[__] kids
the the the kids that did uh what
happened he was telling me how he
started as a one thing for Adam
and now he was in charge of all the
video you see on the DVD the the footage
behind the scenes yeah yeah that's what
he did he goes I went from being nothing
to stick it out for five years editing
these videos and now I run the whole
behind the thing so we've been talking
one day and I go let me ask you
something Let's Pretend let's pretend I
have this friend
and
I send them in here what's the system
and he goes well he come in
and right now the way this company is
moving and growing with the amount of
movies we're doing
he'd be holding wise for a year and pick
up garbage and opening doors and getting
coffees and [__] like that
and then you get into the Union I think
it's tough to get into the union or
something like that yeah well I don't
know what reunion it is but at least
it's you have to have a certain number
of uh non-union days to qualify and then
you have to figure out what you want to
do and sign up for your prayer I don't
know what the [__] he was telling me but
he goes listen bro a smart little
hustler
this company
two years two and a half years if he's
smart
and he knows how to make moves they'll
make a position for him
who make though
plus he learns everything along the way
I went to this guy this [__]
associate [__]
and I said to him dog I just talked to
my friend his name was Jason at the time
I haven't spoken to Jason [__] 10
years I don't even know if he's still in
the business
and he said he would hire you and they
would hire you for a great salary
I mean you're not buying homes in
[__] Bel Air
but I think it was like 750 a week it's
five days a week and you might be there
till midnight but you know you qualify
for you you're not doing anything else
right now you're working every other
month there's a [__] associate
producer doing nothing doing nothing
that's a life of a PA that everyone
you're absolutely right everyone thinks
they're gonna move out here and be a
producer first and some people are and
that's great but
no it's not gonna pan out no no it's not
gonna pan out you're going to be a
producer's assistant for a while
yeah for like a year you know what I'm
saying coffee and that's not great
either meetings
manual yeah but you're understanding his
world before you dive in completely I
agree with that for 90 days I could take
orders and take yellings and beats for
90 days if I got a credit card and if I
know my uncle's selling fruit and I
could [__] part-time him to death I
wouldn't mind to learn the business I
like to get paid that's fair enough if
I'm there even if it's 50 a day at least
throw me a half a yard so I could
commute and make it happen with a
[__] smile on my face it's not after
the 30th day that didn't turn your shift
for credits I understand that
but I like to get paid while I learn
what I do so you have to start from the
bottom like right and it's very funny
you mentioned like when you took when
you stuck to your deal there's been
Stories the past few years about interns
at various big studios they're like oh I
think it was like NBC like me like they
they couldn't go to the bathroom or
something or and went before that at SNL
was like oh we didn't learn anything we
just got coffee those people when they
sued the places that gave them
internships and I I guarantee not one of
them is working in the business nor hire
anyone who sued the place that gave you
an internship that's what interns do
like as an intern I was working nights
not supposed to work nights as an intern
digitizing tapes
but [__] it you do whatever you say yes
to everything
and it seems like the older you get or
the more experienced you get you just
get to say no to a few more things
that is [__] crazy
that is crazy that's like I mean why I
came here it's like extra work yeah [__]
yeah it's like extra work and I gotta be
honest with you guys I was an extra one
time in the tape in Seattle
and that was in the time on uh two
What's that show I was on that they made
me an extra one I got that oh um was it
two and a half man no the other one the
[__] another one with the [__] near
nerds and fake Three Chicks Big Bang
Theory you know one of those you know
what's funny man I was thinking no no
How I Met Your Mother what is it How I
Met Your Mother How I Met Your Mother
you know I was thinking about the other
day
forget about people in your life
you really forget about situations in
your life
I knew this guy for a long [__] time
Hello Goodbye
he was always [__] very quiet around
me
every once in a while he would talk to
me about some
between you and I I knew he wasn't
interested in what I had to say you know
[__] I got arrested
my name came out in the paper
and I Disappeared for four weeks and I
didn't see him for a while and
eventually you know he found out that
was me in the paper he put two and two
together he wasn't stupid
and I got out of jail
I got out of bail
and I [__] saw him like three days
later
and that day was a little standoffish
but then he turned and he called me over
when he came over and he asked me what
happened
and he goes is it true what I read in
the paper and I go you know you can't
believe what the [__] you read but I was
involved in something
and he asked me what happened and he
asked me what was I gonna do and
and uh
and this guy says to me listen I gotta
be honest with you
always have a suit on you know I know
you're a Salesman
but your demeanor I would love for you
to work for me
he goes for years I wanted you to come
over and sell insurance I just didn't
know how to get your attention
I was like oh you [__] said that's
why you look at me all [__] weird all
the time
and he goes I could just tell there was
something about you that I forgot I
could get you selling Insurance you'd be
a good Agent or whatever he goes I guess
that dream went out the window now
you're gonna have a felony what's going
to happen to you
and I go uh you know
I don't know I don't know looking at
the 15 [__] years I don't know he
asked me if I was going to flee I said
not at all you know I don't think so
where the [__] am I gonna go and
one thing led to another man he would
see me and wave and wave and wave maybe
three months later he said to me hey man
are you working and I go well I'm kind
of working you know I'm working
part-time hand I'm doing this I was
selling a little Coke you know you know
me I was never on the straight narrow I
was gonna go at that time I didn't know
I was running away for sure
and he came up to me one day bro and he
goes listen man I don't know if you need
to work or not if you want to ever uh
claim my insurance office on Sundays
bucks a week I'll take you an hour
vacuum take out the trash
dust clean off my desk Shred the
paperwork
I said sure
for [__] years I did that with John
Lee I never heard about this yeah
because I was just thinking about the
other night the guy's name was Ray
old Ray
and on Sunday nights he would give me
the keys to his business and I'd walk
upstairs not once I ever think of
robbing or looking in a [__] desk
because the trust was so [__] amazing
my name had just come on the paper for
kidnapping [__] somebody
so you don't want to [__] it up
I lied that I couldn't believe this guy
was doing this
I had seen the reaction of 50 of the
people I knew when my name came out in
the paper and my
and my [__] whatever
but I cleaned his office
that last Sunday before I got sentenced
that Monday
like I [__] cleaned it every Sunday I
would go there at 10 in the morning and
it would take me an hour
I take the trash down and vacuum and
vacuum the whole way out of respect
I do it all for the [__] small Deuce
because what the [__] the guy gave me a
shot that's how much the guy [__]
believed in me you have no [__] idea
how many people believed in me this is
the universe sometimes you don't have
family but sometimes the universe has a
certain way of letting you know they
believe in you
I got locked up two months later I got a
check from him
he hunted how to get a money to me and
he said he owed me 200 so he put 200 in
my book he never came to visit me he
wrote me one letter
and when I [__] came out of [__]
jail
I went over there and he asked me you
want the keys back you want you to drop
back I saved it for you
that's so nice did you take it back [__]
yeah every Sunday even at the halfway
house it would get me out on Sundays he
vouched for me he said it would take me
four hours
because I had to take a bus up there it
was [__] 10 minutes away on the walk
that's amazing
I can't imagine you cleaning that's like
dog 200 hours to clean up in office what
Pride what [__] Pride that's a
problem when everybody said everybody's
got Pride that they what they won't do
right yeah you know and granted I was
doing blow but I also had the ability in
those days to make four or five thousand
a week selling cars
I chose to hustle and I did that it
wasn't I would just get stoned I would
get weed
on Sundays and get high and clean the
office
with an iPod on whatever the [__] a
Walkman on
did he get pretty good at it you seem
like you're from a lot of Pride one hour
dog and then I would do extra things he
would hire me to paint the offices
so I would do little [__] things for
him
not one [__] [__] that I had with
that guy when I left Boulder that was
only one guy I probably went there I
kept in touch with him
after the earthquake when all the
[__] money went up with all the uh
you know the earthquake here in Los
Angeles a lot of people moved to Boulder
and he
he made money and he [__] sold his
house and I lost contact with him
but I can't believe that he was like a
[__] angel that came out I had
another guy in both it was a [__] old
guy that had a kid and a wife I told you
that I lived I dated a girl that lived
upstairs so that's where I got the rocky
apartment downstairs
because I went to Seattle
and and I paid rent and [__] and when
they call the house to see if they had
gotten my money order for the rent and I
never heard back from them
and then one day I went to do comedy and
one part of Seattle and I see the sun he
goes you didn't hear the news
right after you left my father got
diagnosed with cancer he got 90 days to
live
he goes they tried to write you a letter
so they put all your stuff in storage
for you and paid for a month we don't
know if you lost or not I was
heartbroken I lost my mother's pictures
the baby's toys I lost a bunch of [__]
because I was gonna go back to Boulder
and pick up all my stuff and put it in
storage and give away and see the baby
once he told me that I was [__]
horrified but that dude had kids and a
wife and he was old and after I dated
that girl she left I took the apartment
downstairs well me and that guy I used
to come out at night he'd be out there
by himself and I used to offer him weed
this guy was older than [__] Lee
and he would take two hits of weed and
every like once a week he would smoke
pot with me and then I started taking
him to the movies with me
like what are you gonna do sit down
let's go to the movies so me and him go
to the movies on Monday night they go
man I do more than we usually when I do
with my kids I always had that
like I I never understood people having
parents and not getting involved with me
when you went to 18 movies with your dad
I laughed at you but I loved every
minute of it you were both High that's
what we do man that's what him and I
like to do we just uh
we go we've gone to movies my entire
life
400 episode [__] and as usual
we never forgot you know what I'm saying
here you go Lisa come over here sit next
to your Uncle John it's time for a
[__] come on hurry up before the
[__] song ends in
oh we're still young
what's with the breathing heavy
cause I'm already high enough you're
never high enough for you I took the
problem with America remember there's
always high enough nobody's high enough
that's why they eat oxycontins and they
how long does this take Lee for the love
of [__] Christ let's do this
we're going deep it's the 400 episode
people stealing pills and their
grandmother come on let's go come on
we used to do
suck that negro Lee there you go
lift that [__] thing that's Grandpa
drop that knowledge
loves company
there you go see who's better than you
look at you
what the [__] is better than Lisa yeah
there you go
back to Tony Bennett oh
the truth of the matter is let me give
some shout outs real important one right
here to my man Mark Pacheco it's his
birthday today
happy birthday ball sniffer my man
Darren Hughes Jose Collazo Michael Mosey
beautiful bipolar my man in Jersey Joe
Canyon Joe Ammons Owens Michael Angelo
Rex Riot one by one podcast had hero
[__] Junior on smoking it they're
gonna be here August [__] 29th I'll
just be getting back on the 30th
from the tour uh what else is [__]
going on John Cutler you know all the
[__] that have been with us
since day one Bobby and Crystal my girl
Uki getting ready for Austin they're
sending you pictures of barbecue oh my
time to send you pictures of salads you
ain't doing no [__] Barbie are you
gonna come in line with us huh You're
Gonna Come wait I'm not in a million
[__] years [__] no dog
I love to kidnap you and tell you we're
taking someone real close you know where
I'm staying and you know where I'm gonna
eat nine meals
that's it I don't go away I don't stray
from my diet you want to go wait online
and bring me back barbecue be my guest
but if not
I mean [__] gumbo with a [__] crab
and avocado salad as usual is that Papa
Doe's or Pappasito's Papa Doe's you know
how I roll [__] if Pappadeaux had a
whole an Airbnb would you stay at that
Airbnb the secrets upstairs that comes
down with a pole like [__] Batman
that's exactly where I would be like a
fireman you know those poles they come
down just like that right as they open
at 11 A.M right when I open for two eggs
bayonettes in a [__] piece of fish
nice red and fish for breakfast yeah you
want to live to your [__] 90 to get
yourself a nice red and fish okay two
egg yolks eat [__] two egg yolks and
a piece of fish and see what happens to
your body
nice grilled fish a little black him
like Cajun style you've been trying to
get me on this fish I can't I don't
understand how the [__] you don't eat
fish it really tastes good never not not
but you eat tuna from [__] uh Subway
this is what you understand what I'm
trying to say I haven't had two in
somewhere for years okay so at least try
something you don't like salmon no well
when you eat sushi what the [__] do you
eat I eat tuna okay and uh shrimp and
shrimp yeah pretty much you say I gotta
live with people doing in [__] shrimp
uh
what fish have you tried ladies I've
tried everything what have you tried
I've tried Cod they've been you big Cod
you put what did it taste like it tastes
like [__] Fish Man
I don't like I don't know but it's in
I uh we'll talk about it on an episode
later but I I just I I'm signed up for
blue apron and their first
couple meals they're gonna send me like
they send like three meals a week
and like couple one week has caught and
one week at salmon so we'll I'll let you
know how if I like it now but as a kid I
didn't like it all that stuff is how you
prepare it yeah you know I used to have
a friend that used to make me a a nice
piece of fish a white fish with a nice
texture and he put an aluminum foil with
garlic and butter and lemon and I
couldn't taste the fish dog
you just gotta figure out a way to I
like broil fish
you know there's no reason to eat fish
if you're gonna [__] fry if you're
gonna Grill it nice now we got something
to [__] work with I forget what what
comic it was it might have even been
Dean cooked but it was like here you
don't like fish
so if you like it didn't taste like fish
why are you eating it
just like eat something else that you
like to taste but listen I don't like
all [__] fish Lee me either I don't
like all the fishes out in the [__]
Lobster how sad is that that's that you
got to be smacked in the [__] head of
juvenile Lobster you should be shot hung
and lit on fire [__] what do you mean
you don't like [__] oh that's but you
had the spicy Lobster up at that place
that was [__] delicious but that was
fried and had spicy sauce but I don't
you don't like lobster dipped in butter
nope I can see that you eat clams
fried and clam chowder you've never put
a red sauce on the clam and suck that
[__] I've done it a couple times
it's just it's like it's what I imagine
it's like to swallow like a [__]
it's so it's squiggly it's terrible how
do you know that's what I would uh one
time I don't know I had no but I I my
dad worked at legal seats some people I
tried everything I like it I don't like
you know what I like uh swordfish is
pretty good but that's really like meaty
that's like pretty steaky it's steaky
yeah but it's got black spots on it and
when you eat that black spot it's like
[__] emulsive of cod it's the heart
of the [__] fish oh really yeah if
you bump into those stains whatever they
call I don't know exactly what they're
called it's like I used to eat a lot of
that stuff on kebabs right so I take
swordfish cut it and put on a kebab with
green peppers onions bell peppers and
some shrimp and I'd marinated like a uh
what's that [__] they give you the
Japanese restaurants soy sauce like a no
the other one the [__] Japanese ones
when they throw [__] knives up in the
air and [__]
I had a sauce like that I used to
marinate the swordfish overnight you
come home you put it on the [__]
Grill
it's all over see half of that stuff is
the marinationally
it's like lamb you ever have lamb I
think the best [__] thing in the
world it's delicious I don't like it in
a lot of ways like I like I like veal
scallopini and [__] like that but lamb
is too gamey for Uncle Joey since I was
a kid I'm not bigger than that last
night
no but
growing up Mrs Hartman used to take the
[__] lamb cut it into cubes and
marinate for two or three days
and then she'd take that lamb and put it
on a [__] Grill you thought you were
eating the Kebab but you were eating the
lamb chunk that was juicy delicious it
would melt in your mouth and I ate two
thousand of them at one [__] time
and I didn't give a [__] it was lamb
it's how you marinate that stuff the
same thing with fish my wife makes
[__] horrible salmon God bless the
soul she [__] tries it's a nightmare
I need three pieces I gotta throw it
away and give it to the cats when she's
not looking
the cats are looking at me like we can't
even eat this [__] salmon it's either
dry then I was buying it from the place
already with the marinade on it and that
was even worse
I talked to my wife about like a man I
go I couldn't even eat it Terry so she
looked at the [__] YouTube she went
we went over it and we bought it she
started buying this garlic butter
and it's completely different now
it's completely different she marinates
it a little bit she puts it on a [__]
Grill
it's tremendous
I think fish is marination and how you
cook in preparation I'm down to try it
man you you have this urge to [__]
become the chef of the future lately you
bought the [__] kettle pie it was
great no no no I like that you don't
leave
um dude I've ate out concerns I gotta
tell you something the other night I had
a conversation with leave at my head
almost blew up at one in the morning the
next morning I realized that
sometimes Lee is just crazy and you know
what man marijuana makes you do some
[__] weird [__]
because when I first investor in those
Stars I couldn't stop
that banana bread had us going crazy for
a while first off you're eating a piece
of [__] pound cake with chocolate
chips in it and thought eggs and butter
yeah it can't be good for you that clogs
up your [__] arteries right and now
you're eating potato chip stuff and
[__] uh what was I stuffing in my
face for a few weeks those
those captains booties oh pirate pirate
booties that belong to my daughter my
wife will be furious aren't very many
calories dude listen I don't give a [__]
you shouldn't be eating those [__]
things the other night Lee told me he
got wings from where
Pizza Hut now wait a second no
okay I went to I went to big wings once
I don't like big wings okay I'm sorry
the one one I had I had an experience
that was not good
there's no Buffalo Wild Wings that close
you one time for your honors for exhibit
a one time you had Pizza Hut at your
daughter's event I think an event it was
delicious she's three she wanted Pizza
when you're three and you want pizza
first of all all the pizza's so bad in
this [__] town that it doesn't matter
the reason why I got Pizza Hut is
because on Friday at school they got
Pizza Hut
so when she told me she wanted Pizza
I got pizza hut that I enjoy I thought
it was [__] garbage I didn't see you
saying it was garbage well I can't hurt
her feelings and say this pizza sucks
dick if she doesn't know if you eat all
the slices and she eats the cheese
that was the only time I ordered it late
because there was a three-year-old that
wanted pizza and I wanted to go to the
same Pizza they eat at the school
ever ever in my wildest imagination
just because of something embedded in me
will I disrespect who the [__] I am at
any level at any point in my life even
when I was doing eight balls of blow and
I had no respect for myself when I
disrespect Myself by eating that [__]
pizza and letting people know I gave up
on society and I gave up on [__] I
can't do that well that's why I got
wings I think I only got wings so you
just called down there and got six wings
and they got eight wings and I did I
picked it up eight Wings you went all
the way down there I was already [__]
little AIDS and festivals and they were
good they were big ones I just can't
believe that you have no idea you see
the workout he posted today guys I gotta
be honest with you guys and I'm not
blowing smoke up Lee's ass
half of you guys that listened to the
podcast cannot do that workout he did
today and I know somewhere at least
stopped and breathed heavy no but I will
tell you A lot of people can't do that
that's what pisses me off about Lee tell
me the whole time that at this age she
puts this much work in
to go over there and get yourself hate
wings that are not only
I mean listen we're all trying to be
[__] individuals here in this time of
fakeness
you know if you were watching this uh
I just I don't give a [__] about a lot
of things I was trying to explain this
to my wife my wife is a gentile
my wife is a [__] Gentile
I don't know guys
I don't know if it was a retardation I
don't know it's because my grandmother
was married to a second cousin I don't
know what the [__] it is but when I was
a kid I didn't really care
for what Society cared about
there was just something
something weird about the media to me
growing up
I didn't like how they'd say things I
didn't like how they did interview
people as a child I remember going what
the [__] is that interview with somebody
there's a murderer outside you know like
[__] like that I never liked it I don't
know Lee I was always a weird kid it
just didn't add up to you you know I got
old I didn't like Saturday Night Live
I didn't believe
what the [__] you know
whatever and I gotta tell you something
I really don't give a [__] when people
come up to me and tell me these things
like uh like I'm looking I'm like you
have time to give a [__] about this
and I feel like there's a lot of people
like that that you know just sometimes
we all do when I went through that
divorce that's all I thought about
you know I was in involved with my
daughter in the divorce and my feelings
were hurt so all we had to do was talk
for three minutes
and I would tell you about my anger and
how she was a [__] dirty [__]
and I get it I get that I get you coming
up to me and being upset because you and
Paula break up I understand that
but for you to come up to me and be
throwing things because
Bernie Sanders
gave the delegation to whatever or there
was just so many things that I've seen
of [__] and you know how I know that
[__] because I know they don't give
a [__]
nothing bothers me more when people
really don't give a [__] and they make
believe they give a [__] it's every four
to eight years you know brother if you
give a [__] do me a favor go down and
live with those [__] projects with
them for a month
and get some cops down there and we'll
make sure there's no shootings down
there we'll make sure we'll let them
know Obama's in that [__] but
you would never do that you were always
sleep in your bed
these politicians they go up there and I
saw this as a young child and we've
discussed this before
that I as a young child I saw people
just talking they don't give a [__]
about you they're just going after you
so tonight as I was leaving the [__]
VP on Hillary Clinton was talking
Spanish the word Spanish you ever heard
in your life meanwhile he's got a green
[__] Spanish dude that he whips back
there once a week and hasn't given them
a raise in 18 [__] years because you
know it's just like it just guys there's
times I want to [__] pack my bags and
just move somewhere somewhere simple in
a [__] jungle where you gotta send me
telegrams through a monkey who gives it
to a bird I'm down who gives it to you
because this is just it's become
something
through the middle of all this you got
[__] people chasing people in parking
lots which I didn't know what people
were talking about I would listen
I don't know what people are talking
about when they talk about Pokemon I
ain't got a lot of nobody I have no
[__] idea
I don't know nothing when I was a kid I
think do you want to know anything right
you know what I'm not interested
but then [__] parking lots and [__]
Parks filled with people Central Park
did you see that that guy rammed into a
cop car the one the [__] Isis is
getting stronger by the [__] day
every day we do something stupid Isis
get stronger I can't believe we get
hacked and we blame it on the [__]
Russians hat right away they blame them
under all the Russians the Russians that
Trump paid the Russians to [__] it we
live in this [__] uh and it's so oh
my god when people were crying that she
got nominated I'm looking at this going
oh
they just went into the fair if you
think the Obama [__] purple
[__] what did they get those people
to drink in Jonestown Kool-Aid they gave
him [__] Kool-Aid wasn't bad enough
now they're gonna get these people
hooked on and listen I got a daughter I
got a [__] wife I was raised by a
single mom I want women to [__] drive
but Hillary Clinton is the [__] devil
incarnate though yeah she she wrote and
there have been other women from other
parties nominated until that and then
but what Bernie Sanders he said there
you could see he was eating I don't know
what they gave that poor guy
I don't know what they gave them I guess
they [__] chiseled the amount of
votes
GNC what's the place to get the vitamins
I don't [__] yeah
see the GNC [__] them up
poor birdie Sanders listen politics is
[__] dirty guys oh yeah no yeah this
is gonna be in the history book [__]
Phil oh yeah it's gonna be in the
history books because of the filth and
you know what it really doesn't matter
at the end we're still gonna have to
[__] get weapons and protect
ourselves we still gotta [__] wake up
every goddamn morning and [__] work
you still got to do jumping jacks you
still gotta hug your kids and it doesn't
really [__] not to talk about
politics but what about the people who
for both
um conventions watched like the everyday
24-hour day scene and coverage of it and
watched all the speeches
I throw my wife out
I tell her you gotta go you gotta go get
some sun place you went to the park and
do two laps came back sweating and [__]
she's like Joey I ran today because I
was too late for Yoli yet cause you got
to get out she'll sit there and believe
in all that [__] I won't let her get
involved
she calls her dad and they talk those
two [__] Geniuses back in Tennessee
you know
let me guess her dad's very Pro Bernie
he felt the burn I have no [__] I
never got involved
involved even [__] ass do you
understand me I don't know nothing
that's the rule of the church you know
I'm not you don't want to know nothing
once they start talking about that you
do that noise beep hold on I got another
call I'm gonna and you hang up on him
and then they [__] call back they
don't know I just imagine you're doing
that to them in person I do that all the
time because they don't have a call
waiting no I'm saying like there's times
I call my in-laws they don't have a call
waiting right so I [__] with them from
time to time sometimes I'm on the phone
with them and he starts going off about
girls softball and the girl throw a
fireball and hold on we got another call
people I just hang up on them and then
my wife calls him back what happened I
don't know the phone went dead I'm there
talking to my girl software and then him
and her get on the phone I got saved
you know hi I'm dogs please I always
have an Escape Route oh my God I'm worse
than Spider-Man I always have a [__]
Escape Route but what do you do how do
you get out of a conversation in person
because that's what I thought you man I
thought you were gonna say there's
someone in person I got another call
just walk away
all right
first off you see somebody coming you go
for the [__] iPhone
you put that phone up there and you put
a sad face on like your uncle died
that's the only way you're gonna shake
them dog
is that like difference like not as sad
as like a parent does no but not as like
they can't be that [__] [__] and
talk to you after you drop that bomb on
them
they can't be that [__] [__] they
might want to console you though yeah
okay consume keep walking keep [__]
walking I don't want to talk to no but I
got to make funeral arrangements here
keep [__] walking it what the [__]
you want to talk about
I think the worst thing ever done to me
was my wife forgot an ingredient
and something she was about to cook and
right before I killed her she sent me on
a mission this is when we lived on
Schrader in Hollywood it's the worst
thing that's ever happened to you oh it
kind of whatever whatever
but the problem was this wasn't that
wraps I didn't have to go two blocks
away I had to go up the [__] Cahuenga
to the Spanish supermarket okay
they have a uh uh what do you call that
[__]
Delhi uh a Mexican supermarket on cuenga
right before the 101 on the left-hand
side I think some Arabs bought it but I
used to go there when it was Mexicans
that have the chickens hanging they
roasted chickens they had a little
Mexican food every day they had soups
they were working under the radar you
know what I'm saying but they had like
they made a mistake on coconut water
they were giving you the big big ones
for a dollar fifty when they were 10.99
I was going and then buying a ton of
them those Mexicans didn't know what was
going on I love that you found a good
deal oh my God they didn't know they
would make everybody else had them for
like eight bucks they were selling them
for 199 they made a mistake
they thought it was a 16 ounces they
really had like the 32
I was going in there every day and
getting two or three of them for [__]
two dollars a piece nobody knew I didn't
say nothing to nobody I didn't tell
nobody about that sale this was a nice
little Spanish market right on cawanga
and they had nice steaks cheap nice pork
chops you could go in there and they had
fresh meat on a daily it wasn't a a
corporation you know what I'm saying it
was just a couple Mexicans the same ones
you see up here on Burbank Boulevard but
you get nice meat up there that one
place right there where we drive past
all the time on Burbank Boulevard
it's like they have the foes and all
that they got like Foe and Chinese
cuisine I would never go in there
because they're mixing Flags I go in and
I own a lone man they give me four I
gotta stab one of those Asians you
understand I gotta go out of that
flaming with [__] knives
so but next to that place is a Mexican
market where they got the goats back
there and you get them stabbing animals
and chickens it's as fresh as [__]
they got those soups with the chicken's
feet in them and then I went in there
one time I'm like I gotta bring Lee in
here this is real [__] Bogota right
here no you don't yeah you could get the
soup and the chicken's feet are in the
[__] soup can I not get that can I
order that no no how are you gonna marry
that chick if you've never what if they
break that out the [__] wedding they
don't take nothing out no what do you
think what do you think they're gonna
cook at the wedding in front of you
hopefully a whole a bunch of delicious
tacos but anyway to get back to the
[__] conversation we were talking
about right
but I want you to experience it I wish
that one day with today's gonna happen
somebody calls you up and says do you
want to be an extra in the movie
only going to take two hours
I just want you to walk out and say suck
my dick and you're going to do that then
someday somebody's gonna contact you for
a real movie
and I want you to do that you know come
to me and say Joe I got a letter from
the union they want three thousand
dollars I'll never act again police
someday all these things add up
and one day when podcasting goes to
where this is gonna go
and I'm dead and buried
you're going to be telling people you've
been doing this for 30 [__] years
and you're gonna be 50 years old and
you're gonna command the big salary by
that time who knows if they'll be
television
you'll be like the next Maury Shaffer
well thank you man but I mean you you
you're always very nice to me remember a
couple weeks ago we talked about me
going to the i o and you were in shock
weren't you there was I having this
conversation with you I don't know and
you said to me why would you run away
write sketches
was it you were reading from the
flappers remember we're on the side and
I told him for a while I thought I was
going to be a writer oh yeah for Io and
I went and took a sketch writing one and
two and three and they go what did you
get from me like I realized I was better
than the teachers writing the sketch but
I still went in there that I want to be
a sketchwriter no right but maybe I
might learn something I paid money to
pay for those sketches and between you
and I you know I wouldn't say this to
you I was better than those [__]
morons
they weren't doing nothing better than
me no no they weren't right they were
writing for like some [__] show on
the channel that was before e
whatever before he even it was uh girls
Behaving Badly remember that show the
guy was like an assistant writer for
that okay and he was teaching a course
like 200 hours like the same thing they
tried to do to you at flappers
so he was an unqualified guy to teach
this [__] job
so yeah it was a waste of time as long
as I tell you an Asian chick came up to
me today and solicited me when I went to
buy this [__] bong
got to tell you something it blew my
mind like all my circuits went what'd
you say what do you think I said
it was the most subtle [__] thing in
the world
it was an Asian girl and a white girl
okay did they look like hookers not in a
million [__] years white girl was a
muscle
white girl was the smoker
okay okay
Chinese girl was in there
short skirt nice shoes
did she pass as a hooker not a million
years to me
after I got in the car
I made a left and I made a right just to
see if the cops are following me
I was on Lankershim
and I pulled out of there
and I went to the gym and I made that
sharp left
and then when I got to tahonga I made
the sharp right and I made sure there
was no cops following me
get the [__] out of me after she
propositioned you
she propositioned me in the weirdest way
okay so after I got in the cars when I
really thought about it I've never liked
Lancashire
in fact who got propositioned five years
ago at a club in Lancashire Lisa yeah
guys Lankershim creepy as [__] that's
creepy as [__] at night and the haha
Cafe is there but now it's on the other
side and I haven't seen nothing creepy
on that side it's really nice on that
side of Lancashire Lankershim is cut in
half
by Riverside maybe or one of those
Camarillo was one of those ladies and
gentlemen I'm not [__] map Google it
[__] but the other side when we
first moved the elite lived in Sherman
Oaks so at night we would do the podcast
and we would meet at night but the high
and we'd be standing outside and see the
amount of women walking by single
and I would sit there and go something's
not [__] right
because they're not walking on the club
side remember what a girl took you in
proposition here in the bar right yeah
whatever the name of that bar is
stinkies or sketches if they were
walking on that side I get it that they
parked and walk to the club right but
they would walk on that side
and they were a always dressed okay B
they didn't look hookery
they were Pros
they didn't make eye contact with you
but I would sit there and go what an
uncommon amount of single girls walking
on Lankershim every [__] night yeah
you wouldn't think there were hookers
right especially when the actions that
way okay so the train gets off okay but
that's still [__] four blocks from
the [__] train yeah what woman would
walk [__] more than four [__]
blocks at nine ten eleven o'clock a
[__] nightly
so something wasn't right
and then I saw somebody started telling
me more I asked you know Junior and I
asked Jack
and they started telling me by that
corner that mattress store there's a
hotel
there's a hotel off Lankershim you make
a left right when you pass over that
there's a vitamin store I used to get
weed there I used to do the theater
there that first right there's a hotel
in there okay and then I I didn't see
him till that day there I saw a black
chick out there like a year later in the
daytime
and then I put two and two together so
nothing you know me dog now years ago
when I first lived in Sunset
there was one day I went outside and
there was cops everywhere with [__]
guys running away from cars and [__] and
I found out later that if you pull over
for a hooker on Sunset
okay so think about this
that if she propositions you or you
proposition her I really don't know the
rules
that they give you a ticket and they
take your car
so dog when I was on Sunset and if I saw
those things I just looked straight and
[__] put the windows up and lock the
doors just in case Lee I didn't know in
those days that those days Sunset was
really bad you know I would always think
that they would be the cops how could
they not I I don't know if you remember
yeah I don't think everyone up there but
I used to live on Van Nuys on no even
worse Sherman Way and Sepulveda
and driving up and down Sepulveda at
night
it was like what hookers what they tell
you hookers look like a movie now but
they in cars no more a couple times like
I would see them like this one time in a
gas station one pulled up and they went
and got condoms uh that uh there's a
Ralph's over there on Burbank and a
couple of them got dropped off over
there I saw but most of them are just
walking up and down the craziest one was
when I was going to work at like nine in
the morning and there was one walk still
at nine in the morning
I would always think one of those would
be a cop I would never pull over
especially now with all the internet
stuff
anyway I don't think the internet people
would be cops too so
I don't know I I don't think I could
ever do it
well today was the slickest
move ever
oh
I couldn't go to jujitu because I still
didn't feel it
so I had a meeting
I left the house about 10.
I went to a weed store
I dropped the baby off at school first
with my wife I went home I sent some
emails
boom ten o'clock I went to the weed
store I had to go to CVS
I had to pick up some notebooks for
tomorrow
and then I shot over to the coffee shop
and I rode for a while
then I went back to the house ate lunch
and then I went to my one o'clock
meeting
so this is what I'm trying to
chronological today and so people know
why my mind is blown
I went to the meeting I probably talked
to the guy for like an hour 15 minutes
I got in my car I remembered
I missed a call from Lee because my
phone was in my bag
I didn't know that at that time I got in
my car and I shot over to get the bomb I
was thinking about calling you because I
was hungry at that time I was a little
hungry and when you don't eat for a day
you want to eat something dirty
like you you crave grease like the other
night I told my wife I craved Donuts at
two in the morning
those those powdered Donuts that come in
a six package uh disgusting yeah I
haven't eaten those nobody is that's how
sick I was oh we didn't even finish that
conversation so I got to Riverside I
went to Lankershim and blew my parking
from the bong store right and as I walk
in there's a white girl with an Asian
girl now between you and me the Asian
girl's got to be 28 29
she's uh I don't know what the scent she
is she's not Filipino or darker or Thai
she's
either Japanese
or Chinese
and just like like a seven like not like
super pretty but like
pretty face not pretty face did not look
like a hooker at all to me
and then the white girl was like a 7-2
you know they were both dressed okay
whatever and then I went in the guy goes
hey give me one minute good to see you
what happened and I go uh we left the
bong in the bathroom and somebody stole
it so he rang them up
and then he walked over to me and they
stayed looking at Candy you know in the
places right and he goes which one I go
give me that one
and he goes it says 40 no discount but I
get like I just keep the 40 bro you're a
good dude and [__] and as I grabbed the
bomb she was right there
and she goes nice bomb you want to party
and let me know what the [__] to say Lee
you know me I just froze
she had to be 28 years old I didn't know
what the [__] she was talking about
me no no no no no no I gotta get home
I'm running late I said something
cowardly something stupid
and then as I opened the door I let them
go out first
and that's when she turned she goes I
don't know what type of party he was
talking about I'm talking about a real
party you could either have me or you
could have both of us
because uh we could work something out
and I just looked at it and kept walking
Lisa
beep beep I opened up my car I got in it
I started the car and I drove away like
a little [__] [__] that I am
did you get like a boner no no I had the
opposite of a [__] bone I had the
feeling that the cops were about to jump
on me from every direction just for
opening up the door for them
and I was gonna get shaken down on
Lankershim in front of all my friends
and people would see me and my wife
would ask me what happened
and that's what I was [__] concerned
about because you know what I'm saying
that's what you're concerned about when
you're a [__] [__] and then another
sexual you thought it was a attraction I
just didn't understand why a woman would
say that three in the [__] afternoon
only if it was even that
on Lankershim Boulevard she's an
entrepreneur
no no I didn't know nothing something
didn't smell [__] right Doug I don't
blame you I don't know dog I would never
solicit them anyway and I would have
never sometimes they talk to you and you
know like you get a feeling like if it's
a black chicken she talks there
sometimes you oh [__] yeah you gotta
have fun with them you just can't
dismiss them and run away like on the
way out of the MGM Grand at six in the
morning to catch a plane hilarious don't
come right out you know me I always got
a coffee and I try to smoke a joint and
play a [__] video game for 10 minutes
before I get in the [__] club for 20
bucks and at 6am they just come right up
to 5 a.m they'll come up to you and you
know what they'll sit there and you know
what man you could talk to them and
break their balls like come on you still
got your room key [__] yeah I still got
my room key what do you think you want
to go upstairs and have a date come on
can't see your flight this is the best
[__] you've ever had and you just keep
[__] playing and giggling you know
the cameras are watching
so I don't touch them I don't I don't
even make eye contact I just go listen
the cameras are watching you sit tight
show me the [__] Goods let me see
that for speak to me old toothless one
oh I'll say something crazy and they'll
say show me the cash and I go listen I
gotta catch the 635 flight I got [__] to
do and they giggle
and they run away or they'll ask me if I
was in a movie or if I was in the
longest ride if I want to have a date
and I giggle with them these chicks were
too up tightly
there was no foreplay
there was no what type of reefer do you
like there was no type of I've seen you
on Periscope salesmanship there was no
salesmanship if they wanted to cover
cops to do something and it was funny
because when I drove around
I saw Cop Car Magnolia again that's my
drug dealer old school paranoia I do not
do cocaine anymore I wouldn't be
paranoid but it's funny by the time I
got to Magnolia I saw a cop car
patrolling
so you never [__] know me you never
know who the [__] you're talking to can
you imagine Lee what would you do you're
going to you know you you're a nice
Johnny sweetness you asked me you want
me to go buy a bong and I said no I'll
go what would you have done if you would
have [__] walked in there three in
the afternoon and China won in her
[__] hot assistant you know no money
was ever said nothing see I was kind of
stupid I was like maybe she just wants
to smoke the bong and then hook up like
when she said party I was like oh maybe
[__] no
when a girl looks like that she has her
own weed why would she want to smoke
with some fat [__] old degenerate
like me are you [__] crazy
if she would have came to me and said
anything else but the way she did I
would have probably been in jail right
now because I would have talked to her
and then you know what I would have done
I would have goofed on her
come on I got like 22.50
and then she would have said 22.50 what
what is that include you know I'm one of
those idiots
right because I like to make [__] fun
of him and [__] like how about I give
you yeah you've done that for years it's
only two dollars and a pair of [__]
socks from woman yeah your torturing
could have almost got you on like to
catch a predator or something yeah so I
just I didn't even if they would have a
sense of humor and said listen we'll
call girls we'll stay at the hotel down
the block are you interested in going to
a party
I would say nah you know how long you
girls been doing this I would have done
like a fake background check and [__]
maybe I'll have some Armenians go over
there and visit you I don't know nobody
who the [__] do I know
I know who you [__] know me
I was thinking we were talking about it
in a different way but I was thinking
about it in this way man
La is a crazy [__] place just
like in the place where I grew up I
would never see a there would never be
some propositioning someone
I did like this place is crazy
on every [__] level
when I was growing up I never saw a hook
on the streets in North Bergen New
Jersey Union City
you know I didn't know where you
contacted them at that age I didn't know
and I didn't want to know when I got to
be about 16
there was a rumor going around on a
woman that lived on 81st Street and
whenever the light was on you were
knocked on the door and for 40 bucks you
sucked your dick oh 40 bucks
I would have done that every day
40 bucks in 1980
was really 80 bucks Lee
I never went over that I was always
scared but that was the only direct I
didn't know what she looked like I never
met her and then years later I saw
hookers in Manhattan
they used to hang out by that [__]
thing by the Lincoln Tunnel
it's funny when
you know my daughter Goes to School in
the area there's a park
close by it's the worst part
um and it's so funny that sometimes I'm
driving at 9 30 in the morning and I see
a [__] hook and me and my wife would
just look at each other like what the
[__]
it's 9 30 in the morning then were you
with me one time when we saw one and
with Josh Wolf over at the thing and she
waved we I saw her years ago I don't
know if you remember we went to Panera
one morning randomly before the podcast
even started I think I don't even
remember why we were there and the the
girl with the blonde hair that would
always walk through the like surrounding
towns we saw her new pointed her out and
I was like years ago that's like at
least three years ago she was black with
a wig yeah yeah I showed her to Joshua I
used to see him all the [__] time and
one day I was like oh my God I saw it by
Gelson's by the white supermarket
they're banging those on those old Jews
in the corner she was taking their
[__] lunch money and sucking that
dick you think I'm kidding you who else
goes to Gelson's Mexicans don't go to
gals and black people don't go to gel
since Jews and these [__] Gentiles
brother Gelson's so she would [__]
suck dick
over in Gelson's
there's no cops ever at Gelson's
no that's a good place to suck dick I
guess
listen I don't [__] know what he
bothered me for it was conversation you
wanted to talk about oh I just wanted to
finish up the wings conversation so
anyway you said the chef of the future I
got a crock pot and
because you kept saying like oh the weed
and you're eating like as I was like as
I was eating the wings that night I was
like I'm not even like it got to the
point where I'm not even enjoying it and
like I can't even I couldn't even blame
it on the weed I wasn't even that hungry
on the from the weed
I was like [__] so I got this crock pot
and cranberry chicken and brown rice how
was it pretty good yeah that means it
sucked this
pretty pretty good mom's good as the
wings but no
brown rice cake is never that great
especially Ricky you but you know what I
love I know that's not great for you but
corn on the cob it's it's better than
french fries it's better than french
fries you're absolutely it's better than
buying the [__] ice cream a little
bit of butter maybe some noise you put
spray butter on to save your money well
last night I put actual butter on
tonight I made a bowl so I just cut it
off plane come on
so you're eating healthy you feel better
it's just it but it was just you
basically saying you know why am I doing
those workouts and then eating and
ruining it
I don't know why it's weird
food it just
and at that point like I said I was I
wasn't even enjoying it
I ended up with 418 pounds like not
because I was making the best [__]
choices
418 pounds
I couldn't do a a tenth of what I was I
was doing the one I'm doing today at the
end no
44 years old I would never want that for
anybody how much of a new YouTube class
would you make through which one how
much how much how long into a jiu jitsu
class would you make at 418 do you think
so 11 years or 40
53 is 42. at 42 the guy at the Y I could
not walk up a [__] thing of three
minutes
what the [__] do you think I would have
done in jiu jitsu
I cannot walk an elliptical machine no
the other one the flat one that you
elevate the uh the treadmill treadmill
for three [__] minutes
without turning [__] purple one time
I had a heart examination and they put
the ink in your heart and they put you
on the treadmill and they [__] speed
it up
I thought I was gonna have a [__]
heart attack
they're like don't worry about you
before the heart attack you're going
through a coma will save your life I'm
like are you [__] [__] oh my God
that's something you want to hear before
you get on that channel no so I was in
that bad of shape what do you mean Jiu
Jitsu I couldn't [__] bend and
they're doing three classes a day
no I do the drill class which is half
and half you break a little [__]
sweat and [__] you warm up you stretch
and then you do the regular class and
then he did a Mobility class which is a
half hour class it's 3 15 minute
exercises dog I'm [__] short today
I don't know I was going to go to
Jujitsu today but I'm still [__] up on
the thing I didn't want to kill my body
today and start sweating I want to build
it up a little bit
so tomorrow I can't do I got a writing
session tomorrow for the special and I
go back on Friday and I'm taking my wife
to date afternoon I don't see born
Supremacy one of those [__] thing you
know what you should see is Mike and
Dave need wedding dates
it was [__] it was funny it was funny
I promise it was funny I promise you it
was funny you also watch Dirty Rock and
you watch but you know what you want you
like that you like Zac Efron and the
[__] girl the girls in it were great
leave me alone
that [__] it was so good don't recommend
them to me because if it's really I
didn't want to see it either yeah you
have to get really high and that's not a
bad [__] that's always a bad suck no
it's not it was it was [__] we died
laughing
it was the whole theater was dying the
whole theater loved it
[__] depressed me [__]
no it was a good movie I promise you I
don't you think I want to go see Jason
[__] born yeah no I don't want to go
see that [__] you don't imagine I got
[__] to do I don't like none of that
[__] I love Matt Damon but after you
suck Liberace dick I lost all respect
from that movie so you just have work to
do it's a [__] joke no no no I know I
know I don't know
let's watch three
three our wife wants to go we get
popcorn we hold hands we're gonna get a
[__] burger and everybody's happy
that's what a family's about right
because sadly she's back to the Grind I
got a meeting Saturday at 10 so she
can't go to yoga Sunday she's got church
Monday and it goes on you know what I'm
saying it never ends the week after that
I go away and I go to Cherokee casino
next Friday
and then the following week I'm [__]
Denver banging out with these animals
and the week after that I'm off and then
I go to [__] uh Oddball then I go to
Austin we go to Austin nice and then I
go to [__] New York City no we got
our hands full dog this Friday I got the
[__] Ice House 10 15 you're
gonna be out of town but that's good
you're taking the wife on a little
Rendezvous when is the the class end the
bar ends tomorrow tomorrow so you're
picking her up tomorrow night well
actually what she did was uh because she
has stayed staying in a hotel because
it's like next to the bar so she booked
the next day just so she didn't have to
check out so I'm gonna go there
hang out at the hotel there and then
we'll go to Newport wait a second before
I hear there are there other people in
the room no you're not gonna play the
Harvey homo game going on with other
girls and boys in the room and I know
she doesn't it's just you and her with a
tub
hers very well she doesn't want to see
anybody done it's over you're locking
you're putting Do Not Disturb in Spanish
and I actually I took a page out of your
book today I went over and I dropped off
some candy and some like just some
snacks for them
and like they actually let me into the
hotel room which was kind of surprising
but they let me in the hotel room and
like set it up and it was like a maid or
night because she was like she was like
it's
anyone out there who's ever taken the
bar or anything it's it's a [__] long
experience so I I'm glad I didn't do it
but then Friday morning you wake up yeah
you get two eggs right you get a piece
of [__] fish some potatoes throw some
potatoes in there Friday okay what what
fish do you recommend I get from the
eggs I have a recommendation I don't
have anything
Deluxe on the bagel count
if you like Loxley but I don't
understand how you like locks and you
don't like it cooked
I don't know what the [__] up world
let's try it I'll try anything next time
but don't get cheap Sam get nice pieces
in like four weeks okay and they send
the [__] nice sauce with it right
yeah you wiping don't [__] around they
send the nice sauce you'll like it it
doesn't come out that drive you stick
right to it so then Friday where you
going you get in the car we're gonna I I
we're going to Newport I take your
advice look at you this [__] oh [__] and
then how and you're down there you got a
view of the beach uh uh close to the
beach I don't know if it's on the beach
because on the beach is [__] like 800
a night which is crazy
but uh it's actually where we went for
our first anniversary now when you go to
these Beach places do you go on computer
sites Expedia and stuff like that and
check it out I'm just curious yeah sure
absolutely dude I spent so much time
what time what website do you go on when
you want to travel I'm gonna I call them
I want a Trivago which I kind of like
except when I went on like I it said
this there was a certain deal and then
when you click on it suddenly it's not
available
what I actually did
and we this is how we actually got it
the first time you're gonna think I'm a
cheap bastard but it actually worked out
they all have these things like
We're not gonna tell you where you're
gonna stay but it's this Star level
so we did that for two years ago
and I literally spent like 14 hours one
day
looking at different things I told you
want to go to Palm Springs but you're
like that takes three hours someday so I
was like I don't want to drive that long
so um
I decided on Newport one of them wants
to go to the desert a horse with no name
if you live in California
who wants to what are you gonna do in
the desert walk around get bit by a
[__] snake but we don't do anything
anyway
room service and watching TV I ain't mad
at you I like doing the same [__]
thing so yeah so that's at like two in
the morning I think it was actually yeah
at two in the morning I was just like
[__] it I'm just gonna do one of those
deals again and I got it it's a
beautiful hotel it's like the Fairmont
Newport
and uh
I called up at two in the morning hi I'm
[__] acid and I was like hey man
we're here for our anniversary can we
get like a nice room he's like oh yeah I
see on here you have a such and such
room facing the pool area
I was like can I get it high up he's
like sure
I called it two in the morning hyena so
let me have some yes sir how high do you
want to get what if there's an
earthquake you and Paula gotta jump
like through [__] moocs in the
[__] mookville you get the first to
the second floor I know you can't get
that because then there's parties and
they're walking around and allow people
we don't want to be away from you you're
facing the pool anyway
you're not gonna really [__] sleep
late and it's a bungalow Beach you gotta
hit people no what's up it's up high
it's it's good and then what if there's
an earthquake you gotta jump no I can't
lose a [__] because you know what
happened today I was driving
from Pasadena and
a highway overpasses and underpasses
where you're either on like big stilts
or you're passing under a highway and as
you're doing you're just like I'm gonna
die one day going under one of these
because it's just gonna fall off and
smush me or I'm gonna be on top of it
and it's gonna fall and it's gonna crash
and fall so you you can't let that fear
ruin your life get higher again what if
you're on the sixth floor and there's a
fight you gotta jump you don't fall get
the second floor cut a deal where you
you want to be up there last week I
checked into a hotel they put me on the
12th floor yeah it's a good four I just
mad dog the guy he goes you [__]
kidding me put me on the second floor
[__] gonna put me on the 12th floor
there's a fire I gotta jump out two room
two listen two three you could jump and
live if there's an explosion on the
third floor God forbid you've been a
good Soul you won't blow up that gives
you a chance to wake up pack up the
sleep at the machine and take your best
jump you understand me jump keep your
legs light you break both ankles but you
know what the 12th floor you ain't gonna
live dog you're gonna go down like a
missile you're gonna have a heart attack
in the air I know you yeah well what do
you say to the person on the phone like
hey man
I like the third floor I'm like the
third floor that's right I feel lucky I
feel more comfortable on the third floor
what would it cost me to put me in the
third floor which quiet
that's how you work that [__]
dog I'm trying to [__] hook you up
here if there's an emergency and it's
even better if you're closer to the back
door you know why
you can sneak out and smoke dope out
there sneak back into your room and they
blame it on the dude on the fourth floor
because you walk up to the fourth floor
and smoke the joint
then on cameras in those hallways
a lot of times I go to these towns it's
[__] freezing what do you think I'm
gonna walk around like [__] Johnny
mook
I'm in a nice hotel I look around I open
up the door I take an elevator up I do a
bunch of stunts sometimes the roof is
off you cause Terror every someone's
like I don't smoke pot listen to me
though
I'll go up three or four floors up go
into the hallway and smoke dope and
leave the joint on the pipe for them
burning and then get on the elevator
I'll put like mint in my mouth and take
three hits of the vapor pen and I'll get
back to the elevator as long as I get to
my room unseen within 10 minutes the
whole hotel will be on the 12th floor
that's how you rock the [__] hotel oh
my God that one time in Tempe that is
the most fun
I had in a long timely but that's where
my mind is
the place in Tempe and the three stories
but on the Second Story they have the
Smoky Lounge that faced
the inside of the hotel okay so you walk
into the hotel people right there you
check it
but then when you to get to your room
you have to walk away from that area and
walk the across this tremendous Palazzo
pool restaurant and business but when
people get together for businesses
conferences right and they're
unbelievable these bungalowsly
these Bungalows have a [__] kitchen
Lee
like the size of my living room with a
refrigerator against the wall you asked
for it coconut water coconut water with
pineapple on it
the red [__] juice leaving on
everything nice so here's these people
having conferences about real estate and
there's another Hut with people having
conferences and there's a hundred people
down by the pool because it's Tempe
Arizona
in his [__] 30 people's eating in the
restaurant and I go up on the second
floor
and I go into the corner and I take a
cigarette and I'll light it
now there's another guy any other song
he's smoking a cigarette he puts his
cigarette out and he walks in
I take my [__] joint out Lee and I
spark that [__] and meanwhile
the whole time I'm smoking this
cigarette like this
with my left hand but I got the joint in
my right hand like
and when nobody watching I may believe
like somebody's calling me and when I go
to get the cell phone I take the hits
off the joint and the [__] air is
catching this
and you can see at the people in both
conferences are looking around and I'm
right in front of them like
smoking the [__] cigarette and they
cannot figure out who the [__] is doing
this Lee I was doing it for three days I
tormented people with this hotel and
have his own
the last time I'll never forget the
third day people were running in the
[__] lot trying to figure out who it
was and there I am on the balcony right
in front of them they have like statutes
for that hotel now because of that event
and whatever year
let me tell you something I never saw
Gentiles in such a state of panic
they were [__] running around Lee the
third day
the Bellman the [__] security guard
of the roof go to the second floor were
you moving around the hotel just a
festival yeah no I've been I'm on the
balcony watching them
smoking reefer while they're looking
everywhere but at me because I'm right
in front of them like
what do they think you were smoking a
cigarette today I wasn't even smoking
cigarettes I just knew that if I the
only reason I could go on this balcony
was to smoke a cigarette
and they keep looking at me and they're
looking at the stick and they're going
it's not him
but what they're not seeing is that I
keep taking my phone not going hello
hold on one second and I'm taking two
hits off the joint blowing it and that's
what I would do is is leave the roach by
the [__] plant there was planters out
there and I would leave the roach by the
plant the thing I got sent for DNA
no no no no no no they do they're like
we knew it we knew it
Billy that was [__] I love doing that
you always have to go on a separate
floor to smoke that's why I like Edibles
so you go all the way up to the last
floor
look in the hallway and then you take
the elevator down so let's say you're in
floor number five
get the elevator up to the 18th floor
you go into the emergency hallway
without setting off the alarm you smoke
you get back on the elevator you exit 10
and you walk down to five
that's the move right there that's why I
leave you with if you're not traveling
to smoke marijuana hasn't worked for me
like a charm plus they can't they can't
they can't figure it out
I'm always worth it the door's going to
be locked in those stairways no you
always double check you put a shoe in
there or something like that come on and
you go up to the [__] two floors up
you burn some calories
what a [__] think you're dealing with
things uh Johnny Bananas and you don't
just prefer just taking an edible and
sitting and staying in your room it's
not like when you're a smoker when
you're a real smoker there's something
about it becoming a party at night
really you go back at night you [__]
get a cup of coffee you smoke a little
there's something about that process
that just the edible is very nice too
but sometimes you eat in edible and you
want some to ease into the edible you
just don't want to go in the shot you're
following xanthea come on you live and
[__] learn give me the paperwork here
listen before we move on thank you very
much for supporting us 400 [__]
episodes people
400 [__] episodes
uh it's a way it could not happen
without you guys
you know [__] talking Lair you know
all you [__] water boxer Cleo
it couldn't happen without you guys or
you guys tonight they're wondering where
the [__] we were that's we were sick as
a matter of fact all sometimes sore
throat
I'm sorry me you okay yeah I'll play no
man I'm dying I'm gonna die I got
[__] new month I got none I'm just
saying you never [__] know that's
part of it leaving your [__] body
oh my God sometimes you just get [__]
you're not gonna get it something has
been like weird for me
really I just want to fuzzy for a second
did you yeah oh you're gonna start [__]
and puke until it
um it's all over she's gonna be trying
to lick your balls you're gonna be
trying to leak out of your [__]
Muffler that's it you've been a cancer
Newport right now and I don't know get
your diploma back because that's a long
drive to Newport while you're shaking
your pants and [__] ain't nobody want to
be with you
okay did you just feel something fuzzy
no no no no I feel fine I did my eyes
but weird oh yeah oh because she did
three monkeys of his death
plus the two more you're gonna do after
we go off the phone it's the 400 [__]
episodes
who gives a [__] that's when you smoke
reefer anybody could smoke reefer when
everybody's hip hop would do smoke
reefer when you have [__] blood
blisters in your throat and you watch
them blow up as you're doing bungets
that's when you smoke them pot I don't
want to share a boat you don't want to
what what are your blood blisters and
your throat that are exploding stop
smoking for a few days what no that was
years ago not blood blisters you got
those little throat polyps and they
stick on them when you cough out they
spit out like a little piece of meat
behind your tooth and you take them and
you break them up and you sniff them you
never broke up a throat polyp what's
wrong with you one of those yellow balls
of death that comes out of your throat
I've never lived I guess
give me a couple more weeks you'll be
smoking some [__] monkeys you'll be
smoking up some [__] throat problems
[Music]
listen a couple weeks ago I went through
uh
I went to a pretty interesting
experience that I've been thinking about
a lot lately
when I was a kid I used to have birthday
parties and my mom used to make me go to
a [__] Taylor and it always seemed
like a nightmare while I was there you
know even though I got two new [__]
suits out of it that lasted a year
because I had grown it was always pretty
nice ever since my mom died in 79 I
stopped getting tables too who's got the
money to pay for Taylor suit you go to
[__] TJ Maxx the fat man section and
they always got some [__] suit you
could wear to a funeral for 49.95 and
[__] one time I bought a magician
good time
listen I was opening up I was doing the
the sunflower Casino one of those and I
was opening up for Diane Ford and David
though
and she says you're unseen so you gotta
wear some type of tuxedo so they had no
tuxedos I went down to Melrose I had the
small 50. all they had in my size was a
guy that was a magician and decided to
quit that land dropped off his gear I
found a magician I still have the
[__] I don't have the tux I live on
fire
but I still have the picture of My
Magician top here's where it gets even
worse guys I get to the [__] whatever
Casino
guess who's dead both David tell
canceled
and whoever else I was supposed to work
at I was opening up the Tim out
here I am with the [__] magician suit
working all week with my man [__] Tim
Allen how embarrassed is I anyway you
want to talk about bad days the reason
why I'm getting to where I'm going is
last week I had a great experience you
know uh
people don't get made to measures too
it's because they're they're not
affordable and available to everybody
you know uh you know made to measure
suits they fit and feel they 100 better
to generic off the rack type suits you
know and you have no idea what it feels
like
to wear a suit
that's uniquely made for you with your
initials in there and to cut the way you
wanted it let me tell you something
indochino is Reinventing men's fashion
and a made to measure suit that is the
best suit you will ever own so suit up
not only will you look good but you'll
feel confident as [__] in fact I'm
wearing one of these suits on my special
all right you get a one of a kind made
to measure suit they customize the
details you want you pick the lining
lapels personal [__] monogram
and more 14 unique measurements go into
making a suit that fits you [__]
perfectly you can't go wrong with a
well-crafted hundred percent Merino wool
suit and that's Merino with an
m-e-r-i-o-n-o let me explain something
to you people every is looking for a
[__] job everybody's looking to do
this everybody's looking to be present
listen I'm a 53 year old piece of [__]
ex-felon do I need to wear a suit to
blow smoke up your ass and seem like a
businessman to you is that going to
change my image no but there's a lot of
you [__] young guys that are trying
to [__] get ahead in the world you
know what man for once in your life take
care of yourself go out on a limb
instead of buying one suit like me and
leave because we're [__] vampires
three suits for 300 because you know
every time I wear a suit there's always
a fire or somebody wants to walk around
with a [__] nail in that shoe and
also I get caught on it but every once
in a while man you want to look good you
want to get that job get yourself and
made the [__] order suit and this is
your shot also you check out their made
to measure dress shirts and Men
accessories money back guarantee okay
this indochino this is the way to go now
today my listeners get any premium suit
for 399 that's 50 off at
indochino.com you have to enter church
at the checkout
c-h-u-r-c-h plus you ready for this one
shipping is free there's no reason
excuse me there's no reason not to try
your first custom-made suit with a deal
this good cold look it up you can't get
a suit like this for 3.99 a classic from
a premium collection that you'll look
good and you'll feel good and it lasts
for a long time do me a favor go to
indochino.com the promo code is church
and we're going to give you any premium
suit for 3.99 plus free shipping
indochino you're gonna look good and
it's your way plus you go down there
they offer you water a nice girl comes
up talk talks to you
they take your jacket off they measure
your shoulders they do a bunch of
measurements they walk you through this
pattern guys that is just phenomenal
you'll feel I'm telling you the 399 is
nothing compared to what you're gonna
feel like when you walk out of there you
understand me so do me a favor right now
you're 26 you're sitting on your ass
you're dead send your credit card and
you can't figure out why you can't get a
job because you [__] look like a mooc
that's why all these kids are looking
sharp do yourself a favor go to
indochino.com right now go look at the
selection of Suits they got listen
3.99 and free [__] delivery get your
[__] together go look at these suits
right now on the way out pressing
c-h-u-r-c-h cut this [__] and get your
life together I'm really happy Anna came
through for me this week I got some new
product to try I got the mixed greens I
got two more [__] uh hemp protein
shakes I got an alpha brain and I got a
[__]
shroom Tech sport I'm back [__] I'm
gonna put this nose to the [__]
test [__]
you hear that I've been [__] douching
it out putting [__] saline in there
it's a nightmare but I've been doing it
thank you for your support and the whole
thing but do me a favor and it's always
on top I'll tell you what else you want
to look into they got if you don't get
no discount on these but I'm telling you
those little clubs that they use attack
fit those little ten pound clubs get
yourself a video dog for your wrist or
if your shoulders hurt but I can only
help you out with the supplements gold
they got the MCT oil they got the test
on testosterone booster they got Alpha
Brain they got new mood on it never
stops but you know what you got to make
the first move go to honor.com look at
the great selection of supplements they
got try one of them Alpha Brain 100
money back guarantee if you don't like
it keep the [__] product smoke it in
your next weed experiment we'll send you
back the check but it all starts with
you go to honor.com and press in church
[__] church
c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 off and get the
supplements sent right to your house
next week I'm going to report to you
that that new green thing they got the
Dr police recommended it's a new lemon
lime flavor I can't [__] wait listen
this podcast is about you [__]
in the growth to Lee thank you very much
for listening tonight I know you
[__] expected fireworks and for
us to do heroin I thought about it but
my health is not the best part right now
I didn't want to ship myself in the
office in front of you people but you
know us [__] we don't back up
you understand me a little Sabbath
Bloody Sabbath tonight I don't know Lee
whatever you [__] think
either than that or anything Lynyrd
Skynyrd I think let's do something let
us give me Give Me Back My Bullets by
Lynyrd Skynyrd I love you guys see you
next week we're just doing one podcast
this week why shoot ourselves in the
[__] leg thank you for the love and
support happy 400 [__]
foreign
thank you